tu as vu ce qui se passe à tous au nom
de quoi tu parles de quoi la radio ou à
la télé les journaux tout le monde en a
le truc mais oui ce matin chez lui au
précis m'attends à tout moment pas à
l'autre c'est foutu c'est que j'ai eu
trois ans lila l'enfant thurien parler
aussi bien sinon par un boy ou s'ils
n'ont pas sifflé au bol ça veut dire que
voici le nouvel épisode tout le monde en
parle
avec thierry ardisson
google
alors oui
tailleur
10 heures
mais vim
et boli
un vrai public de télévision
[Applaudissements]
clémentine célarié
loïk le floch prigent
jani ber
alors
maintenant à moi
chambéry
ja
marie d'un picasso
mais j'ai tout le fleuve
m
pour cela bienvenue sur le plateau de
combat
l'émission l'appliquons piliers du pape
vous connaissez le principe tout le
monde en parle alors tout le monde en
parle
vous connaissez les keable six pick up
[Applaudissements]
à
je vais lancer un assaut mais ça va non
seulement une heure ou deux sebrab assez
bons échos c'est alors la tournée ça va
c'est un policer la folie alors 9
octobre joué-lès-tours donc si vous êtes
une jeune fille de joué-lès-tours la
titoff arrive je vais prévenir parce que
tu fais bien après après le spectacle il
a faim non si avant a patiemment on
organise un petit goûter au théâtre le
10 octobre à rennes
l'appareil pour les filles 1 le petit
goûter le petit goûter
et puis alors le 29 le 30 et le 31
décembre à la salle jean marie messier
boulevard des capucines donc titeuf
c'est l'olympia c'est ça assez olympia
c'est l'ancien olympien oui voilà et
alors le 22 novembre bien la vhs il ya
la vhs le 22 le dvd dvd ventures et
comment on fait j'ai vu c'est vachement
bien ouais titoff et vous n'êtes pas là
seulement pour faire votre promo ah bon
bah non vous êtes là aussi pour tester
les nouvelles interviews que je vais
faire après des vraies stars ya pas de
problème y'a pas de problème vous est
pris on va faire l'interview sigla on ne
bouge pas pendant le jean galle
pour vous le progrès ces tgv ou ivg et
toi tu vas le faire des vraies stars
ouais j'ai pendant je prends mon premier
joker jean-pierre ouais je vais demander
l'avis du public
est ce que la démocratie a plus à
craindre de letea ou de l'ena le nom
lainages et une fois j'ai joué j'ai joué
dans une école pour une école c'était le
polytechnique c'est incroyable ce speed
de fou j'avais pas fini les phrases ils
rigolaient déjà il avait déjà compris la
vanne
ils sont impressionnants ils font peur
votre vie sexuelle votre vie sexuelle
c'est plutôt sas ras ou sos c'est plutôt
s sas sas ouais bah ouais tant qu'à
faire
maintenant que j'y suis puisque chaque
fois je dis je passe pour un obsédé
votre vision de la vie conjugale c'est
plutôt cdd cdi ou sdf en ce moment c'est
ce qui m'inquiète c'est plutôt cdi mais
souvent elles s'engagent et puis après
on se fait battre à la porte on se
retrouve sdf
donc j'attends un bon moment c'est
plutôt sur la longue durée c'est plutôt
ça ouais là c'est vraiment l'amour
[Applaudissements]
kroutov la soirée à laquelle vous êtes
prêts à tout faire pour pas y aller
ah c'est bhl et la nrf pdg et hec ou om
et psg c'est sûrement pas la troisième
là ça c'est sûr non par contre non ça
serait justement de regarder un match om
psg chez bhl avec des pdg
quitte à ce que vous regardez en premier
chez une fille
son cv son rib ou son qi sokü les trois
lettres qui vous font fuir devant une
fille
ces mst ou mlf même et c'est vrai que
c'est bon madoff nom isabelle alonso ces
coquines à bord contrairement à l'image
que tu as triché pas l'image qu'elle
vous souvenez mais moi donc je sais
j'avais le vent souffle pour les buts au
mlf oui oui je suis pour
je dois regarder une caméra oui il faut
dire elle isabelle si un jour on se
rencontre
on discutera je ferai pas le match n'a
pas tout de suite peut-être pas tout de
suite mais après
monsieur
les additions dans cette émission c'est
de rediffuser chaque semaine les
meilleurs moments de l'émission
précédente
ça s'appelle tout le monde en a parlé et
s'est préparé par jean hugues noël
magnéto serge ya un truc comme on le
sait on peut en parler ya prescription
andres est juste tout ce qui veut dire
andré je ne vois pas venir dit que vous
étiez très proche d'isabelle adjani à un
moment où on est et collègues oui on
s'aime colère pourquoi est-ce qu'on vous
copie temps thierry et est pour toi mais
pourquoi et pourquoi
pourquoi ça vous énerve autant ça
devrait vous flatter fait d'être copiés
c'est plutôt flatteur
voilà ça prouve qu'il ya pas beaucoup
d'idées dans le paf en ce moment donc on
rencontre souvent avec deux jeunes
actrices dans l'est dans les soirées
mondaines dans des collègues des kabyles
dans les premières aujourd'hui fumer
quand même pétards par jour bah ça
dépend pour l'émission l'a pas beaucoup
pas beaucoup vous préférez en vo je vous
détestez en vo ma connerie c'est ce que
je préfère moi chez vous 39% des femmes
refusent la fellation et vous je ne
voulais pas vous la posez moi on vous
vous aimez bien comédien dans douze
hommes en colère marini n'ont mangé de
bégon oui ce que vous préférez dans le
sexe et ça c'est très bien ce que vous
détestez dans le sexe l'odeur ma mère et
mon fils il adore votre mission abbas
est gentil alors de ses jantes et des
deux générations
est ce qu'il trouve pas qu'elle a un peu
copié par d'autres mon émission
à propos il y à fogiel il m'a dit de
vous faire ses amitiés vous préfériez
passé la nuit avec anne sinclair lors
sinclair ou bob sinclair lors sinclair
lors sinclair pas très gentil pour un 2
5 perd quand même c'est pas grave de
toute façon le problème du cyclisme qui
sait que si les coureurs ne prennent
rien les étapes du tour de france au
lieu d'arriver à 5 heures de l'après
midi elles vont arriver à 10 heures du
soir
donc il ya toujours du soir mais si
c'est le journal télévisé si vous êtes
vibro c1 librement non c'est un
téléphone portable
est ce que vous êtes
rocco c'est pas la taille qui change
ah bon non mr
on a parlé
barré par monsieur jean rieux
comme il savait la fin d'émission ya
blind test ce soir le thème du blind
test c'est mon nom est une couleur pour
arbitrer le blindage appelle quelqu'un
dont la réputation est depuis de
nombreuses années au dessus de tout
soupçon
monsieur philippe encore dit
[Applaudissements]
non
merci merci pour pour l'enfant ah oui
voilà donc de philippe lortie ses juges
de touche qui vont ce soir orbitre et le
blind test des juges que je touche alors
aidé talia si vous venez à c'est clair
cette fois ci j'ai trop d'e-mails donc
évidemment si vous soufflez vous enlever
un vêtement à chaque fois donc là ce
soir
et puis ce sont ce soir il ya pas
grand-chose enlevés je crois qu'on peut
y arriver sur zone du mal mesdames et
messieurs alors bon on passe au jeu
idiot regio la une de chaque côté
alors c'est comment ce jeu idiot le jeu
idiot c'est le jeu de la chaise musicale
d'accord d'accord
donc elles vont tourner autour de la
chaise qui en l'occurrence est un
tabouret ce jeu est bien idiot et quand
la musique s'arrête celle qui est pas
assise et l'ont très bien la première
car il a ce soir quand la musique
s'arrête
voilà derrière la gagner didier
[Musique]
allez oui allô
ro
non merci
12h55
[Applaudissements]
gagné alors d'abord ce que je vais dire
à mes amis téléspectateurs c'est que
cette semaine le serveur a explosé trop
email sans doute pour thalia alors j'ai
quand même reçu un e-mail ou deux
d'alexis rouages de bourg achard et qui
dit comme bruno de stabenrath notre
invité la semaine dernière je suis
paraplégique et il ajoute ça fait plus
de trente ans que l'homme a marché sur
la lune
ça serait bien avec maintenant on trouve
un moyen de nous faire marcher sur la
terre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maintenant vous voyez briller les yeux
de démentis voici clémentine célarié
non
magnifique rose pour thierry c'est à
dire un petit souci alors s'il ya du
monde l'annonceur goûtant me sens
vraiment bien c'est dit voilà je viens
chez ardisson et même parler de cul pas
du tout on va parler de tennis ons
comment ça va tu es magnifique cette
crise est proche
c'est viviane westwood ababa bien sûr
souhaite elle fait des trucs que c'est
la première fois que je porte une robe
qu'elle va prêter et à elle les
personnes qui travaillent pour elle et
tout et je la remercie beaucoup c'est
vrai mais nous aussi
ian white foot alors clémentine est ce
que votre père regarde oui oui oui
forcément mais bon il m'a dit quand
thierry ardisson te demandent des choses
sexuelles ma chérie dis lui que ces
choses intimes que tu n'as pas forcément
partager avec tout ce qu'il a mais pas
il aime pas quand vous parlez de ça on
n'y a pas que lui quelques fois des amis
n'ont pas tremblé j'ai la trouille c'est
bizarre hein ce soir c'est pourquoi
c'est pas parce que vous avez votre
émission à la elle s'est épanouie que
d'un côté cela elles ne devraient pas
égaler un peu copié mon émission
elle est bonne alors justement on va
rester sur votre père parce qu'il
travaille à la télé oui il était
rédacteur en chef pour porter à fin et
c'est un type très intègre votre père il
était très choqué par les moeurs de la
télé et vous dites souvent ils rentrent
et malheureux le soir à la maison j'ai
souvenir l'un avec quelquefois pas tout
le temps mais des fois triste et un peu
déchiré par oui et puis c'était pas
quelqu'un qui reconstituait l'actualité
pour que ce soit plus sensationnel
dramatique mais connaître quoi
ou alors vous dites vous suite à toute
cette expérience j'ai vécu avec votre
père dit
la télévision est un métier monstrueux
où est malhonnête n'est pas grave si ça
doit être difficile est de rester
vraiment intérêt à vraiment ce qu'on
veut c'est sans ses spectacles mais
c'est vrai que de dire la vérité combien
d'âmes ans bien alors vous vous ai fait
beaucoup de concessions dans votre
carrière pour y arriver
ben non pas beaucoup sinon au début
pourtant vous allez accepter très
facilement de changer de nom donc on est
arrivé à radio 7
meriem en vrai boëme patrick meyer vous
a demandé vous appelez clémentine j'ai
dit oui tout de suite avait pas de
problème
oui puisque c'était pour rigoler disent
elles à laquelle vous avez été assez je
m'en foutais voit l'actrice
voilà et heureusement que je n'ai pas
gardé le nom que beineix vous avez donné
de prendre 7 2 parce que vous vous
souvenez sûrement de beineix non je dis
ça c'est que le diable porcine est au
partage non alors vous étiez au départ
prête à faire certaines concessions tu
as changé votre nom assez rapidement et
puis après non et puis après c'était
fini par exemple quand il monte en vous
a sauté dessus au standard de radio
france pour moi le sexe est liée à
l'amour toile est quelqu'un qui vous
drague comme ça mais en plus je respecte
un homme absolument génial mais après
vous vous êtes viré une espèce d'image
vous avez quelqu'un de et puis après
vous voyez que c'est un homme enfin je
veux dire il a bon il nous a dit qu'il
pouvait vous aider oui bah oui
puisqu'ils voulaient voter les produits
les bons gars et ça je peux t'aider
petit et puis en fait
il y avait une [ __ ] dans la tête c'est
vrai que tous les mecs
un jour j'ai dit un truc je vais juste
rétablir que je veux aussi dire un truc
très vulgaire trop grossier c'est pas
chez moi je sais pas de genre de
l'émission j'ai dit bon je vais me faire
engueuler jeudi qu'il fallait sucer des
[ __ ] pour arriver dans le cinéma
ouais ce que je voulais dire par là
c'est que moi je n'ai pas fait ça parce
qu'il est il est tout à fait déplacé que
ce soit bon enfin avec ça qu'on doive
enfin qu'on a
que ce soit grâce à ça qu'on arrive
réussi ma foi c'est pas que grâce à ça
mais disent les gens ont vu que c'était
vous parlez pour vous en faites alors
vous parliez pour les autres voilà voilà
il va gérer ce soir des millions de gens
non en fait sérieusement votre refus des
concessions aux clémentines vous a mis
dans une position assez marginal dans le
métier oui c'est pas génial
un nom fait ça commençait à l'école à
l'école vous dit quand vous en parlez de
votre cette période vous dites déjà
j'étais trop grande trop encombrante
avec un et deux boxeuses alors que je
rêvais d'être diaphane et névrosée oui
j'avais envie d'être j'ai pas juif un
fils voyez sur une fille très jolie
arrêté rien la merci des voix mais
maintenant j'ai d'abord chez une femme
oui ça j'étais une femme avant d'être
avance jamais jeune fille brûlée
c'est pour ça enfin gérard été formés
très jeunes raconté
parce que meiway elle en a parlé de l
c'était nos vies temps et alors vous
dites c'est la même chose aujourd'hui
parce que dans ce métier aujourd'hui je
me sens souvent un peu au fond de la
classe près du radiateur
oui en ce moment au cinéma je comprends
pas je veux non mais bon c'est pas grave
parce que je suis vraiment heureuse en
ce moment ce que j'ai deux événements
dans ma barre et non mais c'était un
disque oui voilà est ce assez
mais ses deux pieds et mai mais il ya
des moments où il ya un an j'ai tout à
fait des crises de cafard terry vraiment
mais parce que je comprenais pas mais
bon c'est pas grave ce que je veux dire
le savaient pas soit parce que des fois
vous êtes un peu démesuré c'est non vous
ne pouvez pas mais enfin de façon de
faire les choses à fond clémentine s'il
avait su plus tôt que j'étais comme ça
que ce sera comme ça j'aurais peut-être
plus vite fait mon chemin tout seul
peut-être peut-être y était plus
mystérieuse un peu comme catherine
deneuve très comme sa recette la fille
qui dit rien comme ça donc c'est très
marginal en fait j'ai lu dans un journal
que vous passiez votre temps les boîtes
gay
j'aime beaucoup le débat non mariés là
c'est quoi cette histoire après je ne
sais pas pourquoi j'aime les boîtes
quelque chose parce que le sang je me
sens en fait libres parce que j'ai
l'impression que y'a pas tous ces trucs
alors la drague et puis une machin et
puis non mais oui pourquoi que oui bien
non alors donc pourquoi clémentine
célarié mais pas mariés pourquoi
n'est-elle pas marié d'abord bon je
passe beaucoup de temps dans les boîtes
gay on vient de le dire
et puis c'est vrai nom c'est vrai que
vous faites une idée très très
midinettes du mariage les monstrueux un
autre comment ça se fait ça un passage
en fait je sais pas il faudra demander
je sais pas j'ai ouïe pour moi c'est le
truc absolue passionnel tous ceux qui me
disent oui mais bon je suis très entière
forcément en tant que 10e mais tu sais
impossible la présence j'en ai
absolument en fait ça ne m'intéresse pas
ce genre de discours je suis pas j'ai
pas l'impression de t'avoir j'en suis
pas là ça je dirais pas mais je crois
qu'il y avait compté comme vous marier
un jour je veux me marier ici
ah oui je veux me marier alors c'est un
appel non pourquoi chercher quoi non
mais découle chercher quoi comme type
d'homme oui
[Applaudissements]
laetitia larusso on a marié large et 100
j'ai entendu ça non mesdames on est venu
ici un jour désespéré l'abus de jules
tout ça et on a lancé un appel à trouver
fabrice quoi fabrice mais qui de la
classe mais pas chic
alors il ya un truc me supportais pas
aussi c'est l'enterrement de vie de
jeune fille
mais cette idée cette idée qu'on arrête
de rigoler l'idée de façon c'est un
hasard ça l'idée de retirer quelque
chose pourquoi est ce que vous imaginez
ça abominable alors moi si je me marie
george buffet le jeu de fille déjà
commencé mais je veux dire je non mais
non mais je me sentirai vierge impure
pour l'homme j'ai lu que c'est beau
alors bien un problème j'ai trouvé en
fait pourquoi vous mariez pas c'est
parce que vous refusez d'assister au
mariage tout fait chier les mariages oui
ces mariages les statistiques le
prouvent
c'est dans les mariages qu'on rencontre
les gens avec qui on va se marier
autre cause de votre marginalité
l'éclectisme de vos activités vous dites
je n'ai pas de carrière ce que je fais
c'est ma vie je vois pas pourquoi il
faut réduire
vous êtes le théâtre pour moi c'est
sacré oui c'est sacré parce que c'est un
endroit c'est une bulle et c'est un
endroit il ya des moments j'ai envie que
que d'être là à vendre mes enfants je
préfère la plaintive un meilleur des
enfants en fait il ya que là que je suis
bien vous réfugiez laurendeau frau ben
oui dans le truc bidon avec les mains
comment comment on fait que 20
donc voila vous interprétez madame sans
gêne c'est une pièce de victorien sardou
là c'est la version de pierre laville
mise en scène donc pas à la saxe alors
là vraiment existé c'est un hameçon jana
c'est le mélange de deux fins il ya la
femme du maréchal lefebvre ex
blanchisseuse qui a été d'une fidélité
sans faille à son mari et à napoléon et
puis une fille de pontoise aussi que ça
fait vraiment madame sans gêne donc on a
mélangé on a mélangé les deux alors le
rôle a quand même déjà été jouée par
réjane mistinguett jeunes source à
sophie desmarais arletty mêmes sophia
loren qui a interprété le rôle au cinéma
alors au départ vous trouvé l'idée un
peu trop évidente oui je voulais je
voulais pas et passer quelqu'un qui a
compté dans ma vie qui m'a dit
kim a dit paul ii et tout d'un coup je
me suis dit oui et donc j'ai appelé mon
agent laurent grégoire qui est un ami et
puis voilà et puis on épure en là on l'a
fait on a dit on le fait et puis en fait
un an s'est passé et moi pendant ce
temps là j'ai écrit mon one-man-show
voulait faire un one man show un
spectacle tout seul et puis et puis il
était à la lecture au théâtre antoine
mais vraiment argument je voulais plus
fermés du tout et puis et puis il s'est
passé un truc dans ce théâtre incroyable
mémé et tout d'un coup j'avais
l'ambition de lire enfin mais moins bon
et puis tout le monde il est entré sans
gêne mais évidemment que c'est vous mais
c'est vrai le 18 octobre donc au théâtre
antoine
1 c'est pas une comédie musicale alors
comme je chante aussi et des gens
créhange tout
[Musique]
vous placez évidemment de madame sans
gêne à ça ça c'est charles schillings et
pompons f donc c'est quand même lui en
voudrai comment dans une boîte gay aux
cellules à la démence mafiosa bruxelles
ouais et c'était génial ça c'est mais
pour moi c'est extra qui sait de trucs
là je me dis qu'on aime sans gêne elle
vivrait maintenant je pense que l'aura
peut-être aussi rencontré charles x
on s'est rencontrés dans cette boîte
j'entends des leçons qui faisait jamais
bien faire des impros à vaison j'ai des
copains qui ont déboîté tout ça et puis
et puis là je me suis dit je lui dis tu
as confiance en moi tu as un micro tout
ça j'aime bien faire des impros un peu
avec des dj est là depuis c'est comme si
on était mariée alors oui c'est comme un
genre de mais non on n'est pas ensemble
il est très beau magnifique ne veut pas
de moi mais je reconnais comme ça non
mais mais non mais c'est un mec génial
qui disent ah je voyais t il à c'est un
africain métis ilaina un truc de droit
quoi c'est un mec
et mentir je dis pas que vous parlez
beaucoup hein mais vous avez abordé biya
alors on va faire un truc c'est ce qu'on
va faire
l'interview sans la bouche en bouche ma
part dans les guignols
[Musique]
bien alors dans un dîner un producteur
très connus vous proposant rôle très
important en vous appelant françoise
toujours dans ce dîner arrive votre pire
ennemi yeux moufter pas la bouffe est
infect dans ce dîner à chier
[Applaudissements]
alors bon la bouffe est infect vous
picoler effectivement un moment vous
allez aux toilettes
vous vous trompez de portes et vous
tombez sur un couple deux mecs en train
de baiser les accords à la fin du dîner
tout le monde offre un cadeau aux
maîtres de maison parce qu'en fait ce
dîner était organisé pour son
anniversaire et vous avez rien à lui
offrir
ah bon ça suffit
alors vous rentrez chez vous ou en
voiture les flics vous arrête
vous reconnaissez pas à la lie le
reconnaît en arrivant chez vous il ya
une lettre du laboratoire vous êtes
enceinte tu as menti oui d'accord
votre fils vous appelle il pourra pas
vous rejoindre cette nuit ça fait deux
fois cette semaine 1 à votre âge
des ventes et une salariée pas là
[Applaudissements]
avant toi le
et pourtant
[Applaudissements]
j'appelle loïk le floch prigent
[Musique]
oh
merci d'être venus chez nous en premier
loïc le floch prigent et il est très
important et d'ailleurs clémentine si
vous voulez vous rencarder sur la vraie
vie de la république c'est le moment ou
jamais alors été président de rhône
poulenc
vous avez été présent de rhône poulenc
de 82 à 86 ensuite chargé de mission
auprès du ministre de l'industrie
en 89 françois mitterrand vous nomme à
la tête de elf en 93 et omet la tête du
gaz de france
et puis ensuite à la sncf de 95 à 96 et
aujourd'hui vous êtes consultant
international dans le gaz et dans le
pétrole voilà alors entre temps
évidemment il ya une affaire elf
vous avez subi je peux dire 28 mises en
examen oui pas seulement il ya également
six mois de prison
et oui et là pendant trois ans et demi
ferme dans le pré ce qu'on appelle le
procès d'humains sessad en fait appel un
appel en première instance et ont fait
appel
dakar est donc le 16 octobre on va dire
quelle est la date du procès en appel
d'accord donc et puis trois ans et demi
de prison ferme plus deux millions et
demi d'amande plus la solidarité
raveonettes deviers joncour et monsieur
mihara avec amis ont pris de l'argent et
qui sont partis avec
voilà bien alors vous êtes déjà fait six
mois de détention provisoire à un jour
vous êtes rentré chez le juge comme
patron de la sncf et vous être sorti
pour aller à la santé directement
conduit à 2 heures du matin
mi temps 6
donc ce qui vous a le plus marqué en
prison s'il ya hurlements des nouveaux
venus qu'on abuse sexuellement c'est un
truc qui vous a beaucoup oui et que j'ai
dit à ma sortie de prison ensuite les
gens ont essayé de dire que c'était pas
vrai puis un certain nombre de personnes
ont dit bah oui c'est bien voyage
beaucoup de témoignages aujourd'hui et
maintenant j'ai un groupe qui s'appelle
roupies allen d'anciens détenus comme
moi et nous avons de plus en plus de
témoignages qui vont dans le même sens
c'est à dire que les prisons françaises
ne sont pas celles des droits de l'homme
c'est bien que les riches payent un peu
en prison parce que comme ça au moins
maintenant peut-être les puissants mais
pas les riches en ce qui me concerne les
puissants désormais annoncer ce qui se
passe parce qu'avant tout le monde s'en
foutait mais c'est vrai que depuis
qu'ils avaient quelques huiles qui sont
aller en taule
ça aide à faire connaître ce qui se
passe quoi oui mais ç'a toujours été le
cas c'est à dire que c'est c'est comme
ça que à la libération il y a eu des
progrès dans les prisons et c'est comme
ça également en 78 des progrès parce
qu'il y avait les soixante huitards qui
était allé alors c'est dur pour vous
tous qui arrive parce que vous êtes issu
de bourgeoisie bretonne catholique
il est un peu atypique parmi les autres
patrons parce que vous faites pas partie
du sérail
vous n'êtes pas peut être pas partie des
nerfs des polytechniciens des ingénieurs
des mines non moche eu un homme de base
je connais le terrain et je connais
mon industrie et puis je me suis un
familiariser aux transports quand
j'étais sncf ça a bien marché
publié aux éditions du cherche midi un
livre qui s'appelle à faire l affaire
d'état entretien avec eric decouty
alors en mai dernier déjà dans le figaro
vous avez déclaré cet eric decouty donc
il fait le book avec vous que quand vous
avez raconté à françois mitterrand ce
que vous aviez découvert en arrivant
chez elf mitterrand vous a répondu il
faut continuer ce que le général de
gaulle a commencé absolument doigt que
le général de gaulle avait créé l fouet
pour en faire ce qu'ils étaient et me le
président mitterrand avait été sept ans
à la tête de l'état ouais il avait comme
président monsieur chalandon messieurs
pecqueur et c'était il me demandait pas
de changer les choses il me rendait de
les garder
moi je les ai gardées c'est important de
le dire pour commencer à fait alors vous
parlez dans votre bouquin du système elf
alors évidemment ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que elf s'est pas seulement une
société pétrolière mais c'est aussi la
diplomatie parallèle un pour garder
disons surtout le contrôle en afrique
après la décolonisation c'est quand même
lui le grand le grand problème de de
gaulle à l'époque le maître en france
était de garder la place au conseil de
sécurité
regardez les votes des pays francophones
au conseil de sécurité à l'onu
et on a gardé la france est à l'arrêt
mais le résultat est là alors que la
france est restée au conseil de sécurité
alors qu'à l'époque alors que s'il n'y
est pas et que le japon n'est pas oui
mais mais surtout il n'était pas évident
que la france y soit
alors c'est aussi une machine à dégager
des fonds occultes pour financer les
hommes et les partis politiques
alors je conteste mme occulter jeudi au
pack un grand différents cultes c'est
personne ne sait pas que ça veut dire
on sait pas où ça va mais tout le monde
le sait et ce que je dis dans le livre
c'est qu'effectivement le printemps
république le mix des finances le
premier ministre tous et surtout moto
courant donc c'est opaque
moi j'ai dit une fois dans cette
émission que l fêter la caisse noire de
la république et monsieur jaffray a
voulu m'attaquer au tribunal oui bon
c'était une de caisses noires il aurait
vous auriez dû dire une des questions
l'une des caisses mars et cela bien
alors dans le bouquin vous expliquer un
mitterrand que vous verser des
commissions
dont vous savez pas où elle va il n'a
pas l'air sûre prêt lui non pas du tout
pas du tout or j'ai l'impression kindy
beaucoup de bons jeunes hommes coûteux
vous avez la peña derrière une fois à
deux mois près ma deux mois après être
nommé jeudi bois coûte et voilà il ya
300 à 800 millions c'est pas tellement
ou yvon îles russes ou rim du ballon
d'autres choses
oui beaucoup alors c'est pas beaucoup
parce que ces 200 milliards 9 et 16 05
et c'est 0 5% oui de temps c'est
important de dire ça parce qu'on a
toujours l'impression que la pression 7
millions de données entièrement aux
essais deux ou trois forages donc c'est
effectivement complètement marginal
alors en fait bon ben ce qu'on appelle
lobbying en fait c'est verser des
bakchichs versé des pots-de-vin cela
nourrit d'ailleurs vers le noble c'était
d'ailleurs permis 97
rien que dans les traités de droit
financier il était marqué bakchich et
podevin et il y avait une un traitement
fiscal particulier quand on faisait ça à
l'extérieur on était on ne payez pas
d'impôts sur les commissions conversait
je crois pas maïs y est ouais donc
c'était un traitement normal et on
allait voir le directeur des douanes ou
voir le directeur du budget pour dire
voilà ce que j'ai fait c'est ce que j'ai
fait alors vous quand vous êtes le
patron vous dit
soit je ferme le robinet c'est à dire
soit je distribue rien à personne ce qui
est possible soit je veux pas savoir où
sa part absolument pas ce que ça aurait
trop de temps parce que c'est les amis
des amis qui y donnent aux amis tu auras
bon c'est un travail de bénédictin et
pendant ce temps là il faut faire si
vous aviez demandé à l'époque un dossier
en dise on voit l'argent et les biens
des mecs chez elle fit a quand même
suffisamment de gens rim aurait dit
quelque chose
oui mais savoir si madame la vérité il
avait fallu que je vais d'accord je
passe beaucoup de temps mais j'avais pas
de temps consacré à ça d'ailleurs
personne n'attend quand ça casse
voilà donc ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui en tous les cas la lecture
de votre livre évidemment mais c'est si
vous êtes un peu le bouc émissaire quoi
c'est à dire que c'est quelque chose qui
existait avant vous qui existe toujours
et c'est tombé sur vous parce qu'à un
moment il faut bien trouver un coupable
oui alors c'est assez pratique
effectivement de trouver le coupable un
peu atypique qui n'est ni xme
polytechnicienne à un arc qui est un qui
ne pas tellement dans les dîners en
ville notre cru qu on sait bien c'est
bien ça y est on est on est tranquille
qu'on alors les politiques
les industriels sont mis d'accord me
réussit bien le floch prigent c'est bien
alors bon moi ça me plaît pas beaucoup
un peu ce que y'a pas de raison
fondamentale j'ai fait six mois de
prison depuis six ans on embête m'a fait
mal d'être persécuté de précisant à vous
donner des exemples par exemple la
convocation de votre belle-mère le jour
du mariage de sa fille il parle de ma
fille le jour du mariage de ma fille ma
belle mère était convoqué ouais alors
c'est créer une ambiance agréable et
puis ensuite le lendemain on ne convoque
le jour de mon anniversaire
la ville va le liban n'ont annoncé
j'avais pas remarqué que c'était votre
anniversaire vidéo on se connaît depuis
6 ans tous les mains tous les jours que
je viens on marque la date qui émet un
problème non puis ensuite on me convoque
deux jours avant la sortie du livre et
ensuite on convoque ma femme
la veille la sortie du livre et puis on
l'apprend en retard et puis on sait le
doit passer à 8 heures à france 2 et
sort à 7h15 à part ça je suis il n'y a
pas d'acharnement elle tout va bien en
gros ce que vous dites vous c'est que sk
un complot pour vous pour vous désigné
pour faire de vous une victime
expiatoire ya eu complot dans la mesure
où la plupart des pièces qui étaient
chez elf ont semble t'il disparus n'ont
pas été communiqués à la justice et des
pièces qui ont été communiqués sont
celles qui ont l'air de m'accuser ouais
voilà
et donc là il ya un problème puisque
celui qui est parti avec l'argent
c'est philippe jaffré 1 il a créé 250
millions les - au moins après on sait
pas comment il a pris le temps il serait
intéressant de savoir qu elle ad mais
comment il a plus de 259 à dire que le
conseil d'administration et 1 250 lots
dionne absolument celui qui est parti
avec de l'argent c'est lui c'est pas moi
moi j'en ai pas donc voilà on les a
gâchées la batterie ça fait 6 allusion
ça fait six ans que je galère sans
partage j'aurai alors là beaucoup de
bêtises
dertu à avoir de l'argent et à me
défoncer comme je fais pour arriver à
faire subsister bruits
alors vous dites vous en fait je ne suis
pas l'acteur essentiel du truc quoi vous
êtes un des acteurs du tri nécessaires
oui oui tout le système d'état est au
courant et tout le l'appareil d'elfes et
au courant il reste encore dans total
fina elf aujourd'hui des gens qui sont
au courant du système et qui peuvent
l'expliquer et qui n'ont jamais été
convoqués par la justice
plus loin c'est à dire que là le
l'individu qui a passé la le contrat à
madame deviers joncour et monsieur verra
cet individu n'a jamais été interrogé
1 et la société dans laquelle il n a
jamais été interrogé et ce n'est que
hier
ce n'est qu'hier que monsieur perraudin
non pas le juge français aiment le juge
suisse a convoqué pour la première fois
quelqu'un de la société qui a passé le
l'argent à madame deviers joncour et
maybach enfantastiques 1 cinq ans après
non pas le juge français
le juge suisse se réveille il en matière
ya une société classée comme sirven
qu'on laisse deux ans avant qu'ils
évoquent ils s'enfuient quoi je crois
qu'on va plus loin c'est à dire que on
lui demande de parler allemand deux
partenaires académiques que vous dites
c'est l'état qui a dit à sirven aller
faire un tour parce que sakho rester ici
ça peut tomber temps bien sûr on trouve
récentes apportées
est ce que la juge eva joly vous eh oui
clairement rue oh oui ça je pense qu'on
peut dire ça alors sans mensonge est ce
que vous seriez prêt avec suis fan on
human o alors c
très franchement franchement non on est
même allé refusé de lui parler en même
temps ah non j'ai refusé de lui parler
parce qu'à un moment elle a est là que
dépassé la cote d'alerté c'est à dire
est là à chaque fois que je parlais
disais que je montais dont vous avez dit
maintenant je parle plus quoi je parle
plus a duré quatre mois
j'étais en prison et elle me convoquer
toutes les semaines et je parlais pas
mais je parle pas ce n'est ni bonjour ni
au revoir
elle parlait pas loïk le floch prigent
et beaucoup de révélations dans votre
livre
donc on va essayer de les passer en
revue c'est vrai que c'est fort c'est
rare quand même quelqu'un de votre
niveau qui a dirigé des entreprises
importantes public qui d'un seul coup
commence à balancer comme ça balançait
est un mot un peu fort
je dis j'essaie d'expliquer au public la
réalité du monde dans lequel j'ai vécu
dans lequel il vit et donc je dirais que
c'est un peu un mais alors ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que dans les quatre
sociétés que j'ai dirigé j'ai fait
gagner de l'argent au contribuable et
par conséquent de toute la sphère en
question le contribuable a bénéficié et
non pas comme dans d'autres affaires
signé il ya eu un trou dans le budget
j'ai rempli budget de l'état 1
alors vous révéler par exemple que ce
serait les saoudiens qui auraient
financé la campagne d'edouard balladur
en 95
il est clair qu'il ya une enquête sur
sawari 2 c'est-à-dire les frégates et
que cette enquête s'est arrêté ouais
alors il ya des enquêtes qui continue
celle sur ma fortune présumée
et puis les enquêtes sur des choses
intéressantes comme les frégates de
taïwan
vous avez vu qu'il a fallu quelque chose
d'extraordinaire pour qui une enquête au
bout de cinq ans et puis les frégates de
sa voirie de l'enquète est arrêté c'est
en est défendue par la france à la fin à
l'arabie saoudite oui voilà sur lequel
les commissions versées ces 90 arrivent
c'est énorme entre deux heures de 30% de
2 % de commission exactement comme les
frégates et once et de leurs 2 25% et
c'était une période où monsieur balladur
et son diatta de cabinet monsieur basile
envoyait régulièrement l'homme chargé
des commissions du roi fahd qui était à
paris à l'hôtel ritz
voilà donc moi ce que je demande
simplement dans le livre c'est que les
uns et les autres s'explique sur la
présence de cet émissaire dans les
bureaux de matignon à une époque où les
commissions ont été versées commission
officiellement verset puisque l on subit
le même traitement que les commissions
pétrolière c'est à dire qu'elles ont été
visés par le ministre des finances et
loire si tu nous regardes
pour ça c'est la première balle ans et
ensuite il ya la fiba alors ça c'était
la banque du groupe elf qui aujourd'hui
fermé alors vous c'est génial quand vous
étiez patron de l fluvial est la fiba
preniez cent mille balles de 100000
barrage aller pas je dirais pas mais si
geneviève fr je pouvais le faire oui est
incontestablement dans un certain nombre
de cas il fallait que je le fasse
on peut expliquer quels sont les cas en
ccd cas qui sont pas que tout à fait
déshonorant mais je crois que mes jambes
c'est à dire que lorsqu'il ya beaucoup
de gens se soient devant lorsque vous
avez se dire quand même génial lorsque
vous avez lorsque vous avez une
situation difficile dans un pays en
particulier il ya des types qui se sont
fait arrêter et qui sont dans un pays un
peu exotique
bon il faut les sortir ouais bon alors
on ne sort pas parler jugement ouais on
les sort on n'a pas une petite valise et
on les sort et j'ai fait ça alors est ce
que est ce que c'est déshonorant je
trouve ton nom alors il ya bidermann
aussi dans votre bouquin bidermann c'est
le frère de régine c'est celui par qui
tout a commencé à alors c'est le pouvoir
politique vous dites au plus haut niveau
qui vous a demandé de l'aider ou
absolument à lui qu'est ce qu'il fait et
fabriquera des jeans naviguer
essentiellement sur la couture homme et
il a eu génie à un moment de faire de
transformer courage kenzo et compagnie
dans le prêt-à-porter masculin avec
comment le pouvoir politique peut vous
demander à vous d'aider bidermann qu'est
ce que ça veut dire quoi
quelque 5000 emplois répartis sur tout
le territoire dans un nombre d' usine
absolument incroyable et le nombre de
gens qui sont liés à l'entreprise
bidermanas 200 emplois ici sans emploi
là est considérable pressé par le
ministère de l'économie par exemple
quand on demande à elf d'aider un
fabricant de costumes là parce que il y
à des fonds chez elf qui aide depuis
l'origine l'industrie française en
général il ya 420 c'est assez différente
qui est de l'industrie nous aider hermes
vous et des 8-11
lle tard vagues avaient toutes ces
décennies il suffisait de dire de
rajouter une ligne donc le faire c'est
qu'ils avancent le chiffre de chirac
donne tout ça elle va lui répondre
bernadette dans l'hadès venir lui
répondre alors donc chirac vous le
demande strauss kahn vous le demande
d'eric aux voix vous le demande
on voit tout le monde sait déjà voilà
c'est un dossier qu'il faut aider
bidermann voilà un an faites ce que vous
dîtes surtout c'est que strauss kahn se
prépare un point de chute pour quand il
sera plus ministre quoi lui ou son
entourage ou légèrement fait disons que
quand on fait une lettre quelques jours
avant l'élection disant ibid herrmann
on a aidé à la tête alors qu'on sait
qu'on va faire des élections donc le mec
qui sait qu'il ya peut être ministre et
qu'est ce que je vais [ __ ] la semaine
prochaine il faut aider mon pote pour
qu'ils puissent du boulot après lui ou
quelqu'un a été signée strauss kahn
quand même absolument 1 mais il s'en
sort mieux vaut un strauss kahn quand à
wii beaucoup mieux beaucoup parce que sa
marque qui vous savez pas de concert
avec lisez vous n'avez pas su que
puisqu'il a eu un non lieu je vais un an
lui aussi oui bien sûr alors chirac
aussi vous demande donc des débits derma
mais un jour il ya une réunion au rendez
vous secret chirac sirven donc le
distributeur d'argent de elf françois
pinault gaz industriels bien connu pour
renflouer
lusine de bort les orgues qui est dans
la circonscription de chirac c'est à
dire que la chirac dit bah oui moi c'est
il faut que ça marche dans mon quartier
là bas en corrèze on pouvait pas aider
un focus comme ça c'est à dire quoi au
moment des élections
ils voient qu'une usine est foutu alors
ils viennent et puis il faut absolument
la sauver le temps des élections mais là
ils disent il faut que elf donne 5 6
millions de francs à il faut que l épine
au donne de l'argent et il se débrouille
pour alors ça fait un passage par
biedermann qui passent des commandes qui
passent des commandes à l'usiné de bort
les orgues pour artificiellement
permettent son activité pendant quelques
années le temps le temps que les
élections passent alors la mairie de
paris vous dites l'été chez elle 1 chez
elle fasse état de jouer encore il est
clair que là elle était gaulliste
ouais ouais arrêté et que
la mérite pas ça mandat et dont les
habitudes étaient là et s'était même
incongru de poser des questions mais
vous aider aussi vous sos racisme
amnesty international si vous n'êtes pas
assez clair c'est du point de vue
personnel j'ai aidé dans tous les postes
que j'ai occupés
elle souhaite racisme et hamdi kasraoui
tant qu'à faire autant qu'à filer du
pognon à tout le monde autant en fils à
ceux qui font du bien alors jospin vous
l'attaquez pas directement mais vous lui
reprochez quand même d'avoir laissé
condamner emmanueli dans la sphère urba
gracco oui parce qu'ils étaient patron
du parti vous dites quoi mais il peut
pas dire que tu es au courant tout le
monde un ballon peut pas à la fois dire
tout ce qui à sousse qui s'est passé
chez elf le fog et aux couëts et puis
taper sur le coup taper sur le clou puis
soudain se dire voilà j'étais secrétaire
général d'un parti mais moi je n'étais
pas au courant dès lors c'est un peu
contradictoire visite j'espère en
hypocrisie il est numéro deux derrière
bâle à dire oui c'est ce que je l'aimais
je les mets dans cet ordre
sympathique et là on arrive à la grosse
affaire quand même la raffinerie le nâ 1
ça c'est énorme quand même c'est à dire
qui a été rachetée à l'allemagne 1 par
elf 1 256 millions de francs de
commissions sérielle rien c'est 25
milliard travail à savoir
mais d'après la notion est ingéré mais
elf a reçu 6,6 milliards de subventions
1 de l'allemagne
ouais et elle a dû reverser 256 millions
d'émissions sur les 6 milliards si ce
qu'elle a reçus mais qu'encore une fois
le contribuable a gagné 6 milliards 6
mois 250 mais quand c'est à dire 6
milliards trois cents et 1 voilà donc le
contribuable il n'a rien payé dacor ac
l'argent des des inventions était un
petit peu amputé voilà pour les
allemands ouais ouais c'est ça qui se
fait on peut lire cette histoire de
commission donc reversé on a dit donc
elle mode colle tout le monde est au
courant un oui vous vous en parler à
hubert védrine
j'en parle à tout le monde parce qu'on
fait du lobbying et jeudi ont fait du
lobbying et tout le monde est au courant
mitterrand le premier tout le monde
voudrait venir et jouer la perte du goût
au courant mais bien sûr n'imaginais pas
qu'un président se tait nationale peut
ne pas mettre au courant le système
d'état d'une commission de 156 vision il
existerait ainsi que moi un truc en vous
les mettez au courant vous leur faites
pas une lettre au nom du tout vous les
appelez vous les voyez où les 250 sans
nom je leur dis pas de 60 millions je
leur ai dit on fait du lobbying c'est la
seule manière fait dès l'aube et c'est
l'expression robert bakchich absolument
donc là on vient de voir toutes les
commissions
et alors y à l'enrichissement personnel
alors c'est vrai que vous n'êtes pas
parti avec 250 millions comme jaffrès
est clair vous aviez quoi cent mille
balles par mois ou dit oui un mode pas
énorme c'est à dire par rapport à mai à
mes collègues du pétrole 1 c'est de
l'ordre de
10 % ou 5 % et touche maintenant dans le
pétrole normalement les gens d'ailleurs
jaffré lui-même dès qu'ils arrivent
touche 250 mille francs par mois et deux
ans après il se prend cinq cent mille
francs suisses 1 franc par morin
qu'avez-vous cent mille c'est d'avoir
fait l'ena ses comptes passer faut mieux
faire a fait l'ena
quand vous gagnez pas beaucoup d'argent
quand vous avez la 32f pas beaucoup
d'argent mais la carte bleue c'est d'y
aller quand même pas à peu près
l'équivalent c'est à dire que je jeu sur
la carte la carte bleue c'était american
express drive le patient on fait la
réclame pour la mort si on fait de l'art
et la marque se sera jamais aussi grave
que tout ce qu'on entend c'est qu'ils
étaient ceux qui étaient à nuit pour le
président d'elf un pour mes
prédécesseurs comme pour moi c'était de
l'ordre de grandeur du salaire qui était
vu et et par le ministre des finances en
fait il y avait rien encore de recul ça
a toujours été le cas à vous dire que
chalon et l homme le mieux habillé de
france ça cheuvreux dû m'ajuster les
bottines voulez vous payer l'essence est
maintenant n'a jamais payé jamais mais
il y avait beaucoup de gens qui paient
pas les sens tous les ministres de
l'industrie à travers l'un ne payez
jamais descendre quand vous avez des
mises dans l'esprit un jour et tous les
premiers ministres paient pas des saints
oui c'est vrai que normalement quand on
était patron de elf on a droit à un
chauffeur un bureau et une secrétaire
adjoint
sauf moi mais c'est incroyable sauf moi
sauf moi parce que j'ai eu un vote
administration quand j'étais en prison
d'un certain nombre de grands c'est
scandaleux
et voilà donc mais tous les autres ont
l'ont bien sûr et les mecs ils ont été
passeront de f toute leur vie ils ont
une voiture ils se laissèrent ben moi je
trouve ça c'est pour beaucoup ce qui
arrive c'est pour beaucoup ce qui arrive
dans la plupart société française
alors aujourd'hui vous avez quoi vous
vous dites 3 millions de francs tous ces
mots fortune marqué après avoir dirigé
toutes les grosses boîtes grises et
c'est une arme parce que je suis le
président l'ex président le banc coupe
de france même âge mais encore par
rapport à l'ensemble des français c'est
riche donc je ne plains pas je constate
simplement que lorsque l'on parle de moi
il faudrait herry éviter de parler d'un
patron comment le rapport à mes
collègues non mais c'est pas énorme
alors vous confesser quand même quelques
erreurs l'achat de cette propriété la
gêne est là deux millions et demi de
francs alors vous dites quand même là
c'est pas très crédible dire c'est
sirven qu'il l'a achetée sans me le dire
non parce que j'ai dit parc vous dise
que je crois qu'il a acheté oui moi qui
l'a achetée sirven arriver les acheter
et je lui ai acheté 4 millions et c'est
moi qui les acheter ouais avec ma mère
qui l'a acheté non et puis six ans après
on vient dire vous savez il ya le
propriétaire qui a reçu 2 millions sur
20 du premier duel et donc nous en
sommes restés là moi je vais acheter 4
millions pour une propriété qui
aujourd'hui vaut à peu près ça et qui
valait à l'époque de millions simple
donc j'avais déjà surpayés et pas de
raison fondamentale que je la surprise
en cordon pour charmer attendait le jean
sérien gens pour quoi elles servent
haine sans vous le dire va donner de
l'argent propriété il connaissait le
propriétaire peut-être avait-il une
autre affaire avec les îles on l'a
jamais entendu il faudra qu'il
s'explique sur le sujet alors il ya
votre votre épouse quand même ça c'est
l'erreur ça c'est l'erreur vous êtes
d'accord
1 c'est à dire à simon et que c'est fou
c'est leur ai dit que mon épouse
actuelle non mais pour épouser cette
période mais je suis resté neuf mois
marié ses neuf prêtres imams est là ils
ont calé l'utilisé beaucoup la carte de
crédit de f1 peu trop 300000 val
d'europe quand même bien le fisc est
passé ne vous inquiétez pas pour le
contribuable que le contribuable soit
soir mais ces problèmes n'ont pas très
bien le problème
mais pour moi il ya un problème
effectivement ceux ci n'auraient pas dû
être fait alors les 19 millions de
francs qu'elle a touché lors du divorce
qui les a payés n'ya pas lors du divorce
dire lors du divorce personne n'a pu
toucher pas que ce soit ces quatre ans
après qu'elle reçoit cette somme on
après le divorce
moi je n'ai plus aucune relation encore
et rami sur vingt quatre avis un bon
copain cervelle et l'appartement à
londres ça c'est première nouvelle c'est
un appartement alors on sait jamais s'il
appartient à la femme ou à biedermann on
n'en sait rien mais d'accord ce sera
bizarre il est passé lentement là je
vois que même d'eric il serait perdue là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
eh oui pourtant il faut alors il y avait
beaucoup de réactions déjà sur votre
livre ça fait du bruit 1 le gouvernement
allemand a demandé que soient versés au
dossier votre livre dans la sphère le
nhs à wissous content parce que j'ai pas
droit d'aller en allemagne depuis six
ans on me laisse pas rencontrer les
allemands qui veulent moi c'est une
course qui gère très bien
autre réaction védrine et guigou qui
disent qu'ils sont pas au courant
brême au courant de rien mais c'est
normal qu'un ministre ouais c'est pas
courant les mines sont des mots courants
ouais quand ils disent que leur avait
jamais dit que j'allais verser dessus
bien sûr quand j'ai pas et de lobbying
il avait il savait pas qu'il fallait
traduire le bing papin ces pots de vin
normal 1
donc aujourd'hui c'est votre parole
contre la leur oui mon choix disons que
on peut aussi dire que le secrétaire
général de l'elysée ne peut pas ne pas
être au courant du fait que je suis allé
dans le présent république pour lui dire
voilà ce qui s'est passé et je ne peux
pas en tant que président du ct
nationale faire évader 256 moulon entre
guillemets sans que le système d'état
soit au courant un jarrier gamin on peut
faire des jaunes n'importe quoi alors
françois pinault lui dit qu'il a jamais
participé à la réunion avec chirac sur
un évident manque est sûre
bort-les-orgues voir le coach pour les
observe enquête sur voir les orgues
aurait pu être commencer le 26 juillet
96 lorsque biedermann est entendu par un
homme jolie et qu'il a dit oui chirac
m'a demandé d'aider bort les orgues
ouais voilà on aurait pu faire lankais
dont on n'a pas fait depuis cinq ans
maintenant il faut la faire vous
éteignez chez vous ici
loïk le floch prigent pouvez vous jurer
que ce que vous affirmez dans votre
livre est vrai oui bull jurés oui
on va lui
[Applaudissements]
voilà
cardy view attention on ne bouge pas
pendant le jean galle
le matin quand vous regarder dans la
glace ou dit quoi en ce moment mais la
vie est belle ah ben ouais fut bien vous
êtes libérés d'un poids maintenant vous
avez fait le bouquin l'instant eu de
10,1 qu'à un moment il faut savoir
considérer que chaque instant de la vie
convient été gagné par rapport à la mort
vous auriez aimé ressembler à qui quand
vous étiez petit j'avais envie d'être
général ah ouais et puis ça m'a passé
très rapidement mais voilà mais quand
j'étais petit polytechnique vous refuser
de porter l'effort départ au départ j'ai
envie d'être général et j'ai jamais été
générale est-ce que vous quitteriez tout
pour le grand amour
bien sûr on partirait aux philippines
comme sirven avec un an j'ai le grand
amour déjà et je veux bien quitter tout
cas pas si je pars avec ma femme quelque
part aucune difficulté à repartir à zéro
c'est pas un sujet quand avez vous
pleuré pour la dernière fois
j'ai pleuré pour la dernière fois quand
j'étais en prison en vigueur en 1996
ouais et j'ai pleuré sur ce que je
voyais non pas sur moi
un gars que j'ai eu beaucoup de
difficulté à entendre et à passer la
nuit avec ses cris que j'avais entendu
et effectivement j'ai perdu c'est pas
possible que ceux ci existent cimade vie
était à refaire vous changeriez quoi ou
plutôt je pense que je choisir à un
autre pays
ah ouais alors qu'elle par exemple pour
n'importe lequel on va pas celui que je
vis en ce moment mais je dis reste
maintenant j'y reste
et je combats dans ce pays mais donc
vous êtes déçus de la france la traite
l'insigne qui vous a fait le plus mal
c'est l'insulté madame joly qui me dit
vous mentez vous flinguent vous monte
vraiment et vous montez je vais donc
vous pensez qu'elle est instrumentalisé
auquel se sert de vous pour se faire une
réputation
les deux dents se montrent alizés
puisqu'elle a eu qu'une partie du
dossier qui savait que ça qu'elle essaie
de travailler
et puis elle s est fait une carrière sur
moi mais il est clair que les stats re
ah oui elle est star maintenant je vais
quand même en mettant président la sncf
en taule ça marche bien après vous
feriez quoi si vous restez 24 heures à
vivre
s'il ya des choses importantes et qui
pour prendre un peu de recul par rapport
à tout cela dit c'est comme la pêche à
la crevette au bouquet chez moi en
bretagne ou dans la région
c'est à dire en irlande et puis c'est
les champignons cèpes girolles mais
également comme un chevelu email je suis
intarissable sur le champignon j'ai
commencé à prendre des champignons à 4
ans il m'en a empêché des crevettes à 4
ans maintenant 58 ça fait cinquante
quatre angles le fait et pour moi c'est
le la base de la vie la base de la vie
alors le reste
la dernière personne que j'ai eu envie
de tuer alors j'ai jamais eu envie de
tuer personne
j'avais même eva joly n'ont su si jamais
je de quelque chose c'est qu'elle meurt
tout seul
j'ai déjà pensé au suicide quand vous
êtes chanteau là bien sûr bien sûr oui
tout à fait on ne peut pas vivre en
prison sans un moment pensé se suicider
tout ce qui est dit sur le sujet les
gens qui la ramène raison mais non moi
je vais arriver publiés quand on est en
prison un moment on dit mais finalement
est-ce que ça vaut le coup de vivre et
on se pose la question mais je vous dis
en ayant fait ses vidéos six mois de
prison je vous dis la vie est belle
donc il faut continuer à vivre le zélé
retourner en prison un pavillon non
pourquoi voulez-vous ou sur toile et on
essaie de vous le faire y retourner s'il
ya contre vous le fait de complots vous
décrivez moi je referai puis j'essaierai
donc on se connaît on dira vous voir un
logique le floch prigent qu'est ce que
la vie vous a appris appris à la fois
qu'il fallait se méfier de tout est à la
fois qu'il faut faire confiance alors
c'est très contradictoires et je
continue à préférer faire confiance que
me méfier de tous alors si un petit
génie là vous proposez dexc un de vos
souhaits ce serait lequel
je pense que
il faudrait que la crevette le bouquet
reviennent en bretagne il ya une
disparition de la crevette en bretagne
chez moi concert avec le jeu obligés
d'aller un peu plus loin pour la paix
chez et je sois de charme
quand vous parlez de creuzet charmant
des champignons j'étais en prison de six
mois vous avez un truc vachement
attachant c'est vrai vous êtes enfin
faites gaffe avec
jean
contient les gars y levante
8 heures
et maintenant garceau
[Musique]
jean
attention
si haut
si jenny des leurs
[Musique]
parent
messieurs c'est le charme de cette
émission après loïc le floch prigent
jenny bel'air donc vous allez faire des
révélations vous aussi jenny sur la
double et je tenais à dire merci
beaucoup
il est vraiment gentil ça là tu vas avec
10 points et à régler les couverts jenny
bonsoir donc françois janvier vous
consacre un livre chez power qui
s'appelle jenny bel'air une créature
vous savez comment on fait
ça fait quoi d'avoir sa biographie dans
les librairies
je suis très honoré premiers parents
couvert quand même qui aurait cru au
vert des langues et avec sade est où là
c'est une arme bien alors créature c'est
quoi une créature c'est quelqu'un qu'on
aime quelqu'un qu'on comprend pas et
c'est quelqu'un qu'on dit est une
créature créatures d'épouvantables
abominable cette créature est à l'essai
au vote
alors je le dis pour loïc a l'air de
beaucoup s'intéresser à vous vous êtes
travesti mais pas opérer un evous dit tu
ne vas pas beau coupé le téléphone
l'électricité à la rame est perçue est
perçue en tant que toto le film elle
m'agace beaucoup un prêt vous détestez
la norme et c'est vrai que ce qui vous
intéresse en fait c'est d'être mi-homme
mi-femme et pas d'être femme deux hommes
avant tout c est un être humain voilà
alors vous dites je ne m'aime que décalé
et vous dites quand vous parlez de vous
une femme ne m'a pas autant le paquet
des sommes que moi du service d'ailleurs
ryswick faut lui faire le coup de la
crevette
ce qu'il est
avec nous
vous gérez vous vous levez toujours
quand une femme arrive toujours toujours
quand elle voit arriver une femme elle
se lève comme ça voilà alors on va
parler de vous de votre vie du livre qui
vous est consacré
[Applaudissements]
alors aux appels jenny bel'air on vous a
aussi appelé françoise à cause de sagan
ose appeler la négresse mais la [ __ ]
la morue lamoureux hystérique
la ghana la loi n'a lâché yens ouais là
bas moi de me mêler cocasse ollanta
truculente j'ai compris ce que plus
rapidement c'est qu'il ya une chose qui
peut sauver d'étrave lot c'est l'humour
quoi oui à votre vrai nom c'est
incroyable votre vrai nom c'est alain
c'est faux ça va s'appeler c'est faux
oui c'est fou quand même ça s'écrit et
se paie à chaud mais oui on sait c'est
faut voir si c'est pas c'est pas
vraiment le nom de mon père c'est faux
mais je sais il faut bouder vous avez
vous levé parce que c'est pour la
biopsie
oui elle habite médical ça va être
génial de s'appeler c'est faux bien mais
c'est fou s'il vous plaît monsieur alors
votre père a été condamné à mort
oui pour meurtre avec préméditation dur
il avait tué en fait le manque d'un
maquereau l'amant de sa femme c'est ça
ouais il avait tué ils l'avaient donc ce
pas par rapport une crise de nerfs tenez
bafouée et tromper et ben bon il a
zigouillé et puis le bagne way we passé
de l'avocat l'avait quand même mais
sauvé sa tête donc il a été envoyé aux
aubagne l'île du salut où il a connu
papillon d'ailleurs oui lequel papier on
a un peu rajouté dans la rage dans ses
mémoires vraiment énormément rire je
veux dire et
et dans la libération quand de gaulle
supprime le bagne votre perle droit de
revenir en france va pas dans leur venir
en france et votre mère est d'origine
guyanaise vraiment d'un mois est
d'origine guyanaise
elle arrive dans cette france
merveilleuse liberté égalité fraternité
négresse un regard est tout de suite
elle a subi le fameux racisme a rejeté
et c'est donc ce qui fait qu'elles
étaient rivaux comme on dit maintenant
clip est inférieur dépressif alcoolique
elles vivaient dans des bars d'hôtels
miteux tenus par des ex bagnard elle
même avait été répudiée d'ailleurs parce
qu'elle était tombée amoureuse du
jardinier de son père qui était un
ancien bagnard
alors elle rencontre votre père à paris
vous naissez en 53 et votre père devient
lui gardien d'immeuble chic dans le 17e
1 vous à l'école saint ferdinand avec
votre avec votre frère est finalement là
vous découvrez la vie des riches
c'est à ce moment là dans le quartier
vous êtes déjà une petite reine
j'ai découvert la vie de ceux qui ont
beaucoup ouais dans cette vie j'ai
appris tout de suite à ne pas envier
s'ils ont beaucoup beaucoup et il faut
savoir après tout rester là plus rien le
feuilleton maintenant
[Musique]
j'étais invité donc j'étais invité
partout que vous êtes déjà une petite
star est même invité chez line renaud
parce que ses amis votre frère a
sympathisé avec la famille dont le chef
de famille le père est chauffeur de line
renaud et vous bénéficié des largesses
de line renaud pour les pauvres
vous êtes appelés par emmaüs mais vous
vous retournez les vêtements pour faire
le clown quoi pour retrouver une façon
de vivre autrement
moi j'ai l'impression que vous avez
perdu votre micro ondes quoi quoi il lui
remet la pile est mon garçon tu
t'attardes pas non plus un n'a pas dans
la soufrière une pile quand même à issy
a ici et là bas
allez c'est pas payés à l'heure mais au
devoir inscrire leurs biens et leur
rendement des choses un petit peu moins
rigolote c'est-à-dire est violée à l'âge
de 9 ans par le pédophile de la rue
denis poisson ouais c'était une espèce
de d'ordures par le postier aussi
postiers oui pendant que mes parents
n'étaient pas là a commencé un tripoter
c'était très bizarre
c'est là où j'ai senti que le sexe peut
être une douleur affreuse et un plaisir
je comprenais rien du tout hein je
savais qu'il faisait quelque chose de
deux salles mais je ne voulais pas
rajouter à mes parents à mes parents je
pouvais pas parler de ça et vous dit si
je n'avais pas été abusée pendant mon
enfance je serais jamais devenu johnny
bel air alors ce sera peut-être venu un
peu dedans qui est beau et gros avec
dédé niaré des machins avec 56 maîtresse
1 et avec des actions mais mr
rédaction
alors est il
alors mr moeurs de votre mère meurt de
chagrin de désillusions vous êtes
recueillis par la soeur de votre père
tante yvonne vous êtes dans un petit
village où vous là comme vous êtes une
star de nature évidemment vous devenez
encore une fois la star du petit village
qui [ __ ] de service qui fait
marrer tout le monde quoi il n'y a pas
que ça c'est l'époque de la première
sodomie aussi j'ai dit oui là là là là
plus la pub les plus insensés vient que
pour quelques instants pour expliquer
que c'est comme si on était au poignard
des vous allumiez un peu quand même
par le regard ouais encore votre père
meurt vous partez à la dass et là vous
avez une adolescente un peu clocharde un
peu et comme vous êtes beau gosse bah ça
se passe bien en fait l'actrice dans les
boîtes à saint germain derrière le
drugstore au nuage
j'ai connu ça à l'époque 1 c'est bien
mais alors là on rentre dans une époque
évidemment qu'on a connu tous les deux
parce que le nuage ça commence jacques
chazot vous apprend la conversation ou
thierry le luron vous a beaucoup appris
aussi par la suite
et là vous devenez vraiment jenny
bel'air et puis un jour à l'âge de jeu x
18 19 ans vous êtes alors là vous êtes
interrogé par les flics un
interrogatoire assez musclé prenez une
gifle et vous réalisez d'un seul coup
c'est au prenez conscience de votre
différence vite la société te gifle
parce que tu es une grosse [ __ ] blacks
habillés à la mord moi le noeud et là
vous vous dites ça y est la bien moi et
eux c'est pas la même chose ça y est les
gens de pouvoir conquis veulent ils
blanc comme ça ils ont été la société
vous met une balle à dire que tu es
différentes ma poule
tu es donc ou tu crèves où tu respectes
ou alors tout à fait petit tu rends sur
le vice et c'était terrible et là vous
commencez à revendiquer votre différence
lors du succès vous montez sur scène
tout on vous adore vous chantez et on va
regarder une chanson que j'ai demandé de
chanter dans une émission que je que je
produisais avec catherine barma ya
quelques années
c'était bain de minuit la chanson ces
femmes magnéto sauver
gabon
pour vivien j'ai faits graves
tout sourire clé j'ai marché noir ultra
lumineux
[Musique]
mais tu feras
je suis au grain
ni froid
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
m
voilà
bon moment
grand moment donc dans la piscine vide
des bains-douches avant qu'ils mettent
d'étape sur la piscine pour gagner plus
d'argent il y avait une piscine au bar
et au chili ainsi vous chantiez dans la
piscine desbin 2 dans l'émission bain de
minuit et le garçon qui est avec vous
ces geeks les vases carillon qui était
dit joe quesada c'est un playback
ouais par accident guy avait mis au
nuage donc ouais j'ai passé au bessat a
été très très vite viendront 3 40 45 45
et j'ai fait le gars comme ça alors vous
devenez gazoline alors gazole il faut
savoir ce que c'est et gazoline c'est la
fraction folle du gauchisme c'est à dire
à l'époque au début des années 70 il y
avait ce qu'on appelait le phare le
front homosexuel d'action
révolutionnaire qui était donc des
révolutionnaires [ __ ] quoi et la grande
idée c'était d'aller crier bits dans
tous les endroits donc leur exemple un
jour elle rentre au flat beat et à ce
moment j'ai cru que c'est également
certainement mais y'avait pas que ça
quand même c'était j'ai été récupéré par
un groupuscule travesti déguisés qui
avait quand même en gueulant en allant
faire dans les manifs et cetera démontré
que bien avant donc les gay pride
colombo sexualité ne veut pas être
ridiculisé mais était là et qu'il
fallait se faire respecter
oui c'est vrai mais en vain il ya le
phare ça a été important en théorie du
phare s'était se faire [ __ ] c'est une
façon de dire merde à la société voilà
c'était là l'homosexualité vécu comme
une révolution une posture
révolutionnaire dix ans mais
effectivement vous aviez aussi à
l'enterrement de pierre overney qui
avait donc été tués par les milices de
chez renault donc ceva la fois une
dimension tourisme voilà militantisme
important et puis après bon bah si la
période de baba bonne période c'est
sympa cool où vivait à la goutte d'or
vous vendez les livres chez gibert jeune
et vous demandez à vos clients de venir
vous voir le soir je voudrais acheter
artistes y suit naturellement de
zarathoustra je suis quoi maintenant
mais après pour le père gilbert n'est
pas ce que souhaite certainement drôle
alors il le nuage après il ya eu le dos
alors aldo c'est un jeu pas qu'on peut
dire un bordel de travestis de
transsexuels qui servait surtout pour
les équipes de rugby et les pompiers à
chacun son vice bah oui chacun son
métier lui c'est tard le 7 rue
sainte-anne ceux qui ont connu le 7
évidemment annoncée déjà fabrice et
merck était le patron il y avait 8 saint
laurent avec sa bande y avait beau oui
lagerfeld naomi campbell enfin toutes
les top modèles de l'époque de noeuds
avait payé beaucoup de coco s'il faut
dire la vérité
vous parlez de drogue
ah oui non et l'arrco fabrice montrent
le palace ben voilà bel et bien sûr
jenny est parti donc au palace il faut
avoir connu le bal vénitien organisé par
karl lagerfel
jenny arrive sur une gondole à ce que
cette balle bénévoles qui par eric star
qui l'a conçu mais pompiers de paris
vous étiez la reine de la soirée même
endroit warhol qu'elle avait vu d'autres
était médusé en voyant c'est
extraordinaire et vous dit en parlant de
ça cette soirée là vous êtes arrivé sur
la gondole vous dit jamais je ne me suis
senti autant femmes que ce soir là
c'était votre sacre d'une certaine façon
mais c'est déjà arrivé comme ça et j'ai
vu tous ces gens qui avaient tellement
la mode tous à tous ces gens qui ont dû
quitter dans ça qui me regarde je vais
regarder comme ça aux ans et j ai bon
alors voilà je rentre pas dans la
famille mais il me relooke
malheureusement malheureusement un
jaloux vous bouscule vous tombez je
tombais allant là pour dire encore parce
qu'on est très franc mais ronnie aux
sources pdf sont arrivés devant tout le
monde
il n'y a que comme ça par terre et ils
ont vu que j'étais doté de circonstance
voilà donc là vous êtes physio
effectivement au palace vous me
permettez de virer michael douglas un
soir c'est à dire par mois ça va me
laisser rentrer mais si oui c'est bien
folle a remercié maintenant à cannes les
stars qui sont fait refouler à l'entrée
vous avez une définition formidable pour
le palace vous dites c'est la plus
longue fait de l'histoire du monde
je crois que c'est assez juste oui je
suis une très bonne définition et puis
après voilà bon après le sida eu la fin
du palace la mort de fabrice et mer et
vous dites rouvrir le palace aujourd'hui
ce serait comme ouvrir les grilles du
père lachaise la nuit on danserait dans
un cimetière
les personnes qui auraient envie de
rouvrir ses dunes et d'essence total des
fois que il faut laisser les choses se
faire
c'est au t2 par la joie la douleur et de
ce qui c'est moi je ne pourrais pas
vraiment ri pénétrer rentrer dedans
c'est ça m'est impossible et l'amour
dans tout ça
quel amour bah oui vous dites je n'ai
jamais été aimé n'ont jamais vous êtes
j'ai entendu deux fois je t'aime est
encore la deuxième fois je suis pas sûr
ça a été vraiment sincère
un toujours là toujours un peu draguer
ou et c'est parce que j'avais eue si
affinités ouais parce que vont se
préfère entrer ou est ce qu'on essaie
des gens et cetera mais le côté j'ai
jamais entendu ça jamais ou alors ce que
vous voulez c'est du bourgeois cdu vous
dites trousses et la braguette d'un
cadre quel délice à vous faut du mec
avec une cravate une légion d'honneur un
costume bleu plus et s'amuser rejet
c'est tout
mais c'est vrai quand mes trousses et du
cadre c'est vrai je chéris mais vous
semblez déjà rencontré ya longtemps donc
si vous même chez vous et cabré un petit
loupé bourgeois et bien vous met vite et
voilà avait une philosophie de la vie
johnny vous dites la vie est une [ __ ]
mieux vaut la sucer sinon elle te fait
des misères oui absolument
ça choque personne j'espère donner son
blitz h au club house face c'est
vachement ça c'est pas que ça me choque
ça ça c'est dur quoi tu penses tu es gay
ça je poserai moussa comment tu fais
pour pour rester en vie
enfin tu vois pour tout nouvel matin je
me fais un cinéma particulier la tête
je prends des neuroleptiques pour tenir
je vis avec très peu d'argent et cetera
j'essaye de je suis comme ça je me dis
jusqu'à temps que cette moule qui est
devenu comme d'ailleurs ce que
maintenant tout le monde se fait je
crois que c'est effrayant mais il n'ya
pas que moi dans la misère et jeudi
après tout neuf la tête ya pire que toi
[Musique]
john ferreira françoise on peut là
messieurs
sa vie vous ne serez pas étonné que nous
fassions une interview alerte aux roses
ans ne bouge pas pendant le tig
on ne bouge pas pendant les jeans gars
bien est-ce que vous avez besoin d'aimer
pour faire l'amour de faire l'amour pour
aimer ni l'un ni l'autre
vous êtes 23la la fontasse quel est pour
vous le lieu idéal pour une étreinte la
rue la russie des trottoirs c'est un
bordel un porche non la rue nain est ce
que vous préférez un homme qui baissent
bien mais qui est infidèle ou un homme
qui baisent mal mais qui est fidèle
moi je pense que je préfère un mec qui
bosse bien et quatrième on n'en parle
jamais mais il ya des mecs ils baisent
maliki sont infidèles aussi
est ce que vous préférez être caressé
par quelqu'un qui vous répugne ou battu
par quelqu'un qui vous aime
enfin j'ai dit que j'étais une baleine
échouée qui voudraient une crise et non
sur moi mais carey est ce que vous
préférez que votre mec fasse l'amour
avec une autre en pensant à vous ou fast
allemand avec vous en pensant à une
autre en pensant une autre ouais mais
c'est plus sympa clementé rien aucun
sens rien de sens que ça arrive ça c'est
comme ça ça peut arriver
j'ai pas de bons pilotes
[Applaudissements]
non plus en ce moment j'ai pas de max
est ce que vous préférez faire l'amour
avec 1000 mec toujours de la même façon
ou avec un mec de mille façons
différentes 30000 mec là aussi attendait
c'est important ça c'est des questions
mec mais posé les mines mec toujours la
même façon plutôt qu'un mec de mille
façons indifférent minec un remake à
robots peuvent me marier c'est pas
pareil lire la réponse rebelles
c'est plus sympa héroux de vente et non
accusations et bien sûr moi c'est
important tandis que vous dites là parce
que moi après j'ai mes emails touche les
classes
françois
si on veut
à mes yeux c'est très bien
quelques emails poursuivre alors
beaucoup d'e-mails beaucoup beaucoup du
mail pour demander que l'émission soit
diffusée plus tôt ou soient rediffusées
dont un e-mail de michel combas de
prompt par exemple y en a plein alors
effectivement mois puis je peux pas
grand chose il faut que vous téléphoniez
à france 2 au 01 56 22 42 42 01 56 22 42
42 thiery franchement tu aimes bien le
natif d'agen michel g
alors bon anniversaire à christophe de
nine cac 40 ans il fallait qu il ya 40
ans il a promis si j'étais son
anniversaire de pas bougé par le jingle
donc voilà et gérard kervadec de nantes
a une idée pour aider michel blanc
michel blanc c'est ce type qui est en
taule à bali soi-disant avec du shit
mais enfin bon on prend pas perpète pour
du chiffre de toute façon même s'il en
avait vraiment bon alors pour aider
michel blanc et suggère que plusieurs
personnes se relaient pour purger sa
peine bonne idée un émoi jérémy une
meilleure idée ce serait que chirac s'en
occupe parce que ça fait bientôt les
élections
donc si tu veux qu'on vote pour toi
jacques fait quelque chose
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'accueille maintenant marc lavoine
mesdames messieurs
[Applaudissements]
à
ça va super et du beau monde ce soir
alors marc c'est vrai que pendant le
tournage du film de ravalec qui
s'appelle cantique de la racaille on
vous appelez marque ouille ça commence
fort n'est pas comme si c'était arrivé
mais tout le monde fini par l'appeler
marcouiller sur ce tournoi vous appelle
marque aux anneaux tu peux manger me
salue marco et ses chefs bien et quand
il était plus jeune alors on l'appelait
marque quand les grandes failles mais la
main non mais c'est quoi la tête a
grossi les oreilles en herbe plus petit
finalement aller quand même année
toujours des bonnes petites oreilles et
alors il ya un truc incroyable c'est
qu'à la même époque
demarco les grandes feuilles mais tient
un peu du boul vous appelez gras doubles
il était mark williams a reculé à vos
boules jaunes et munitions donc bien
alors aujourd'hui ça va vous n'avez plus
complexes sur votre physique
marc lavoine ou simplement vous dites
mon physique je le trouve plutôt dur
genre nazis couper au couteau alors ça
quand même
c'est terrible ça parce que vous êtes
bouillante ou non mais vous pensez vous
sembler une statue d'arnaud breaker non
non mais c'est parce que c'est un non
match 3 6 9 et 10 à la fin qui m'avait
vu jouer on a un tableau de ce monsieur
ouais c'est le peintre du troisième
reich c'est le sculpteur d3 et par là
donc c'est sûr que ça ça fait plaisir ça
renvoie sur le marché italien et a mis
en confiance tout de suite hein
un peu trop cultivé assez fringants fait
lâcher de presse ça fait plaisir tu
ressembles à une culture de nos breaker
alors votre père vous le jazzman il a
fini au tri postal à vaugirard n'a pas
toujours ce qu'on veut dans la vie et
votre mère avoue être pianiste est venu
dactylo c'est vrai j'avais pensé c'est
pas loin mais arrête avec ses seins
parce que je le fais ça j'ai fait ça je
vous suggère la matière parce que deux
bus excuse moi mais en tous les cas on
peut dire marc lavoine que vous avez
assouvir les ambitions culturelles de
vos parents oui d'une certaine façon
vous allez vous avez fait vous ce que
eux rêvé de faire une certaine façon non
c'est vrai c'est alors vous avez été
élevé dans une culture politique qui a
complètement disparu effectivement
c'était le culte de malcolm x le culte
de la révolution des oeillets au
portugal
cohn bendit votre père vous dis toujours
il est monté sur le lion de belfort ça
ça de le fasciner
c'est moi qui fut possible de vous a été
levée dans ce mode là et quand vous
étiez petit vous croyez que tous les
communistes étaient gentilles et c'est
vrai je voyais tout le monde était
communiste surtout près alors vous êtes
échapper tout ça en partant les
week-ends en mobylette avec des copains
pour tourner en super-8 des spectacles
en plein air donc voilà il y avait un
truc aussi c'est que vous vous êtes
croyants et votre père l'était pas oui
mon les faits un peu le choix
comment vous êtes croyance c'est ça
m'intéresse comment on peut être croyant
quand on vit dans un univers où dieu
n'existe pas ayant vu quand j'ai pris
conscience de la mort
ouais là je me suis dit
on est
voilà on est peu de chose vous êtes
croyante vous de génie quand on a rien
du tout ni papa ni maman plus rien et
que c'est un demi frère
je crois que c'est évident qu'on pense
que marie josèphe lamari dieu tout ça
c'est une famille j'ai abandonné la
prochaine ça du mont sainte vierge
jésus joseph c'est les parents puis j'ai
vite compris que huit c'était de la
tarte
alors bon vous finalement venait d'un
milieu comme on l'a dit communiste 1
avec ce que ça d'humaniste bien entendu
puisque sa terrible avec budapest 156 ou
prague etc et vous épousez la dernière
descendante des rois de pologne qu'est
ce qu'il a dit votre père n'a rien ça va
avec sarah nantes labergue vous ai vue à
poil dans la loi longtemps
oui vous avez une photo de vacances
harris et bien grave puisque convaincant
s'en soit poil sur une plage et des
photos de face si vous les avez ils les
ont alors bon on va terminer là dessus
mais c'est assez assez grave quand même
ce que je vais vous dire là en 97
oui dans le journal l'alsace vous avez
déclaré marc lavoine je suis un mauvais
coup chérie montrez moi ta main avec
jenny lcl a laissé voir barry tu lis
dans l'énigme de l'amour bah oui un très
bon et lorik loïc non tu mon team aux
questions
avec les bandits ni aucun doute oui les
mauvais coups de c comme des interviews
donc à vue parce qu'on sait c'est toi
qui l'a dit où des gens ont dit que
c'était l'inversé lui qui l'avait dit
bien alors votre carrière
au départ vous faites des études
d'imprimerie vous faites à ses hôtes et
d'imprimerie vous apprenez l'imprimerie
parce que d'abord vous habitez avis où
il ya des plaintes imprimerie avis ou
non les imprimés cp2 après ça pousse je
vais tout le temps je vais tout tenter
de colle mais je l'aimé sous efficity en
bleu mais c'est bien d'être en bleu bah
oui c'est bien ouais c'est bien c'est là
où on voit justement fait vrai que les
gens font la différence mais dans des
moments comme ça où on a du cambouis ou
là c'est vrai moi j'étais en blanc moi
j'étais un peintre en bâtiment pour
draguer ben c'est pas pareil
et bien alors bon vous êtes coursier
placer à l'olympia et là c'est
miraculeux un jour patricia coquatrix
vous présente florence aboulker qui vous
présente son fils fabrice aboulker et
puis voilà et puis c'est parti didier
granby demain il
je donne tout du sind et
à la nuit sous la commerçante et
les yeux oui
elle a le
qui tu es là
première mais toucher ces foutus et
l'eba
parking
je ne parle
nous
tu marches
[Musique]
j'vais
qui nous
on
[Musique]
mais
la guerre de la mine ceux ci
tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le dernier les élèves pour mieux
mais le premier single extrait de cet
album qui n'a pas de titre est le
deuxième single c'est ça
là
[Musique]
quand on
et
ottawa j'ai toujours
alors malade
c'est le guizhou ça c'est un duo avec
cristina marocco qui est une chanteuse
italienne ainsi chilienne puis alors il
ya sur l'album en question il ya trois
autres duos in avec françoise hardy avec
claire keim avec souad massi a cessé il
ya eu catherine ringer il ya eu
véronique sanson princess erika
c'est quoi cette histoire de faire des
duos c'est parce qu au théâtre quand on
est au théâtre on est toujours avec des
partenaires ouais c'est vrai que quand
on chante ça manque
fall hélios surtout avec des femmes
aussi incroyable que vers l'action c'est
comme ça
non d'ailleurs pour claire keim c'est en
voyant clair dans votre émission
satirique on la connait c'est clair on
dînait ton temps avec air vous avez
l'occasion non ils m'ont cherché
quelqu'un pour la chanson je ne veux
qu'elle elle m'a dit une vraie appelé
claire et elle m'a dit elle a chanté
chez ardisson s'est très peu incroyable
et donc du coup ça s'est fait un peu
grâce à vous écouter voilà juste très
content
je suis pas le galaxy et mariella au
saut et on a marqué enfin vous inviter
tous les trois avec claire clem c'est ça
marc lavoine j'ai tout oublié
alors marc comme vous êtes un chanteur
vous faire une interview sans pleurs on
ne bouge pas pendant le qinghai
[Musique]
attention marc lavoine est ce que dans
la vie vous êtes plus tôt
ou allô maman moment
allô maman bobo a quand même ou à l'eau
tata bobo à l'auteur pour vous la vie
c'est ou alors c'est bon voilà bien la
vie en rose en a nous vous êtes avec les
filles je ne sais pas ou alors
[Musique]
ouais jojo extra
les filles vous les préférez comme ça
[Musique]
ou alors comme ça
un peu des deux oui une sorte de 9 bon
je les préfère plutôt je suis suis
liberté au fond est ce que vous êtes
[Applaudissements]
ou alors
sexy boy surtout je peux rien vous
cacher vous savez tout
elle servait septième ciel
du thé le huitième album
mais là messieurs
[Applaudissements]
j'accueille maintenant clémentine on
pourra pas dire qu'on n'a pas fait le
maximum pour vous ce soir j'appelle un
autre très beau garçon
j'appelle charles berling
enfin la connaissez tout le monde là ça
va oui j'en doute apte à diriger rhône
poulenc elf
voilà jenny bel'air une amie du cône a
cédé 20 douche
voilà marc lavoine qu'on ne présente
plus évidemment clémentine célarié et
titoff le petit de marseille bon alors
si vous avez un point commun avec jenny
bel'air c'est que vous êtes travesti
tous les deux oui vous souhaitez dans
les mirabelles à l'époque au festival
d'avignon vous étiez travesti pour la
première fois pour la première fois et
depuis ça vous a plus quitté les amenant
à quoi j'ai fait l'année des treize
lunes ce qui était beaucoup plus jeune
et beaucoup plus long j'ai vu oui j'ai
vu j'ai été époustouflé c'était dans mon
passage à gardien c'est magnifique
charles berling n'est pas homosexuel je
tiens à le dire parce que ma façon
vous aviez un petit peu une réputation à
toulon lavande avant de partir il
faisait du théâtre
ouais et à tout le monde quand tu fais
du théâtre ça revient à dire que t'es
[ __ ] quoi un peu à l'époque mais il est
parti j'espère que ça a changé assure à
tous loin
donc il est parti et puis voilà vous
êtes allé en belgique parce que le
conservatoire de paris vous faisait un
petit peu peur quand même temps c'est le
mot qui me plaisait pas mais enfin le
concert conservatoire je veux aller là
ceci étant vous êtes fait [ __ ]
quand même voyage à sec
oui oui je suis une fille magnifique
film d'anne fontaine avec miou-miou avec
mathilde seigner avec stanislas merhar
et aujourd'hui vous revenez ce qu'on
appelle un enchaînement la télévision
aujourd'hui vous revenez dans un film
c'est un film d'anne fontaine qui
s'appelle comment j'ai tué mon père
voilà un c'est comment on fait
oui je fasse le pitch voilà les i je
vais essayer on sait jamais donc vous
vous êtes médecin dans ce film vous
dirigez luxueuse clinique versaillaise
où vous vendez de la longévité faut dire
à des riches
voilà vous êtes marié avec natacha
régnier qui est excellente en bourgeoise
aux antipodes de son rôle dans la vie
rêvée des anges de deux ans qu'à vous
couchez avec votre assistante qui
s'appelle meriem et qui est jouée par
amira casar et vous avez fait de votre
frère qui est joué par stéphane guillon
votre factotum voilà donc médecins
arrivent et qui vend de l'éternité à des
riches et cetera situation confortable
jusqu'au jour où revient votre père
interprété par michel bouquet qui est
parti en afrique et de nombreuses années
en plantant tout le monde dont vous et
votre frère
il revient il s'installe chez vous avec
un air un peu inquiétante ça il
s'incruste et il nous une complicité
avec votre épouse natasha régnait et
puis petit à petit vous voyez en lui un
ennemi d'une certaine façon non c'est à
dire que ce père qui est parti vingt ans
plus tôt
le fils se demande ce qui vient faire là
mais enfin oui ils se retrouvent
brutalement a marché parce que le film
raconte c'est qu'au fond la présence du
père va réveiller beaucoup de choses et
va va montrer que enfin que que sa vie
n'est pas forcément si aboutie qu'elle
en a l'air c'est un oui c'est un film
sur le justement il se croit très fort
mais finalement il très fragile à
l'énoncé
[Musique]
depuis quand et à versailles cet après
midi j'ai certains supports je croyais
que tu étais mort
[Musique]
ennemi pourquoi tu crois emmerder et
vers mu avec toi patrick bien je prends
une photo de 3 qu'est ce que tu attends
en prévenant les trois cartes postales
comment on fait pour tout rayé d'un coup
de crayon on devient un outil qu'est ce
que tu fabriques avec lui
on se voit j'aime bien lui parler
[Musique]
et
qu'est ce qu'il fait là ne t'inquiète
pas je ne fais pas ma course
[Musique]
servian on repart pas à zéro à 75 ans
est responsable et des cycles de la
nature les respecte on passe la main en
sous-titré rosiek ne pas brouiller
tu as vu ça vient petit c'était un
carnage
du coup j'ai tranquillement jusque là ce
[Musique]
mais je rêve d'être le fils de quelqu'un
comme toi comment j'ai tué mon père
d'anne fontaine obliger les banquiers
sans merlin bon dernier amira casar
stéphane guillon alors sur le plateau
est née une certaine complicité entre
michel bouquet vous qui s'est prolongée
par cette nouvelle rencontre qui ont
donné un livre chez grasset qui
s'appelle les joueurs si vous le faites
pour le film mais pas pour le livre ça
avec eux c'est tout le monde non non
c'est pas ça c'est qu'elle regardait
s'est perdue il vous a appris quoi
michel bouquet beaucoup de choses mais
je crois que l'humilité beaucoup c'est à
dire je trouve que c'est une génération
qui a une grande humilité face à la
littérature à la culture en général
beaucoup de choses même monde et que moi
je déjà je suis d'une génération je
trouve plus comment on appelle ça plus
show off ouais enfin plus superficielles
sur sur certains aspects parce qu'on y
est poussée de par notre pratique parce
qu'on a moins le temps que de faire
certaines choses je pense alors à un
moment dans le bouquin vous dites que
l'acteur mal doit accepter sa part de
féminité et même il doit chercher à la
développer
oui d'ailleurs là il résiste un peu haut
débit comprend pas du tout il sait pas
qui comptait pas revenir à bas les liens
non mais mais ça ça m'a toujours
enfin travailler oui dans le bon sens du
terme
non mais j'en suis persuadé d'ailleurs
lui michel il et il est assez féminin
comme acteur il a même cette façon de
marcher sa commune
c'est vrai alors il ya une truc est très
intéressant dans le bouquin c'est
comment interpréter un personnage qu'on
condamnerait dans la vie ah oui pardon
tu doit interpréter un nazi comment je
vais faire moi je pars du principe que
je pourrais être le plus affreux des
types et parce que c'est forcément à
l'intérieur de moi puisque tout est très
rend chacun donc donc sa part de ce
principe là et à partir de là il faut
essayer de travailler pour pas juger les
choses mais pour essayer de les sentir
et de les restituer après il faut avoir
à l'intérieur de ça une démarche morale
anthologique c'est autre chose mais vous
vous n'êtes pas là c'est comme dans
l'arbre c'est comme dans la peinture
c'est comme dans tout art ont fait pas
de l'art pour faire des bons messages ou
des bonnes pensées non denses et de la
matière de la matière qui est humaine
elle est dure elle est forte et elle est
vivante elle est
et je me dis par exemple si je dois
jouer un nazi je m'imagine que je sois
né en allemagne dans les années 10 20 du
siècle dernier et puis je dis une chose
formidable il dit si jamais je ne
comprends pas le nazi de toute façon
justement si je suis contre je ne
pourrais pas lutter contre assez bien je
pourrai pas comprendre comment on en est
arrivé là donc c'est intéressant de et
lui parce qu'ils ont parlé de ça parce
qu'il jouait au foot anglais au théâtre
tout est vrai alors par exemple bon il
ya ça qui est très intéressant et puis
vous dites aussi que c'est un métier
d'obsessionnel c'est à dire il faut
accepter d'être mangés par le boulot
quoi elle s'est même pas des gp
voilà deux heures j'avais envie de
parler avec ça de lui parce que moi
j'avais quand je les rencontre il était
frappé par le fait qu'ils me disais moi
j'ai pas d'appartement ça m'intéresse
pas il a des enfants qui sont pas de lui
enfin il a un rapport à la vie qui est
extraordinairement
je dirais fictionnel et c'est à dire en
fait ils voient la vie comme une chose
mais lui depuis qu'il a 17 ans il joue
et il joue encore et on sent qu'il ne
s'arrêtera jamais de jouer que il est à
naître de fiction carrément donc ça
dévoration intéresser d'autres d'autant
plus qu'il est il aime beaucoup d
acteurs comme lou qui nient ou bien on
voit ça aussi chez depardieu et chez
beaucoup d'acteurs il ya un moment donné
où on est mangé quoi on est mangée par
s'appartient plus lui parler monsieur
parlé tout à l'heure de d'être mangés
par un système un système d'argent et de
l'aide à faire ben pour les acteurs hier
il ya aussi le fait d'être mangés par
des systèmes fictionnelle
il ya un moment donné on peut plus y
échapper on est foutus on n'existe plus
non dire si ça le paradoxe ont vu un
séga aussi pour les acteurs des
transports assure qu'un acteur à de
grosses responsabilités est en fait en
même temps il est dans un état de
vacuité totale en l'habillant le
déshabille si la pâte à modeler quoi oui
absolument cesser c'est le black enfin
que racontée dans le livre quand j'ai vu
pour la première fois je l'avais vu à
tort ou à raison je frappe à sa porte là
comme ça puis j'entends une voix qui dit
oui en prêt alors je vous la porte et
puis je le vois il était en calbute quoi
alors donc je outils mais perdre
enfin pour moi je n'ai pas à michel
bouquet en ce type sur le moment comme
sage et et il me dit non et entrez
entrez ya aucun problème façon les
acteurs c'est comme les pubs cesse des
habits ça sera bus à un avis ça sera
plus donc j'ai l'habitude qu'on me
servir
oui oui alors oui tu un truc que les
acteurs disent assez rarement
c'est à dire le pouvoir médiatique qui
garantit un acteur une liberté
artistique c'est à dire qu'en fait film
hors du pouvoir médiatique quant à pied
on peut choisir ses rôles et ça va un
peu ça bat en brèche cette réflexion sur
cette discussion avec lui parce que je
trouve que ça ça change beaucoup et
d'ailleurs il me le confirme est dire
que aujourd'hui un acteur qui va avoir
de grande qualité
une grande culture et nous avons un très
très bon acteur va pas forcément à voir
pas du tout avoir les mêmes chances
qu'un autre qui sera pour x raisons tout
à fait médiatique donc comme le métier
qu'on fait c'est aussi du commerce bien
logiquement ça se passe le weed de fabas
et maintenant de grands grands acteurs
qui sont et qui sont pas très médiatique
et du coup qui n'ont pas une carrière
c'est ça facile que ça l'organe traque
aussi vous parler d'ultra que vous dites
c'est comme le parachutisme où la chute
libre est monté sur scène c'est sauter
dans le vide c'est au moment où on
arrive on sait on sait plus rien voilà
c'est une espèce de compagnons
nécessaire indispensable et pourtant
souvent très pénible enfin moi ça me ça
fait mal quoi c'est difficile même et au
cinéma c'est bizarre parce qu'il ya des
scènes tout d'un coup on a le trac on
s'y attendait pas et la peur bon en même
temps c'est un métier on ne cesse de
chercher à l'apprivoiser mai mais j'ai
pas l'impression qu'elle s'amenuisent
et quand je parlais avec lui ben je
m'aperçois que pas du tout il ya
toujours le trac moi je dois il doit ils
doivent faire un thomasg beernaert en
mars
enfin fin du mois de juin je le laisse
finissait sa tournée mais arras et après
avoir fait le film tout l'été d'avant
donc il avait passé deux ans sans
discontinuer d'accord mais pas deux
jours de vacances et un moment donné ou
avant de signer le contrat de la pièce
qui doit faire en mars il me dit
maintenant j'en peux plus il faut que je
m'arrête mais il dit ça et et et je le
retrouve à la fin de l'été il a bossé
tout l'été il a bossé tout l'été parce
qu'il a il a peur de ne pas être à la
hauteur de whisky dit aussi vous vous
dites qu'un acteur ça doit jouer huit
l'acteur qui prend sur lui qu'ils
emmagasinent des choses et où vous vous
dites on converse faut jouer beaucoup
comme ça on est souple oui parce que
jouer c'est un mouvement donc il faut
être dans un mouvement dans le sien
propre
et c'est l'acteur c'est pas quelqu'un
qui ont magazine d'état de sensation
puisque l'agent les regards sur lui les
sea dogs surtout une personne et puis
tout d'un coup bas
charles b à l'initial banque et j'ai
cassé
entretien
alors berling ce qu'il faut savoir
mesdames et messieurs c'est que berling
en danois
c'est un nom qui veut dire le petit ours
sur les grosses voitures berlines dont
mahmoud first berling une interview aux
animaux on ne bougera ne bouge pas
pendant le king
[Musique]
à
est ce que vous voyez plutôt comme un
requin un mouton noir un ours mal léché
ou un chaud lapin
à new york malgré l'annoncé alors ce
n'est pas la dernière personne qui vous
est fait tourner en bourrique
ah je peux pas le dire a réussi non non
je reviens ici je peux pas le dire on ne
peut pas le dire non je ne donne pas
pardon ah non je préfère lui dire à lui
un lui il sera très bien qui sait pas
non non je peux pas le dire non non
c'est impossible
non non non je jouais tard en scène non
non tu torture et moi je ne dirais pas
avoir bondi rappellera pas certainement
l'alternance mais moi j'aime bien les la
dernière fois vous avez pleuré comme un
veau peut-être maintenant c'est pour
envoyer un film en voyant no-man's-land
ah oui ouais tu en as vite le débat sur
la guerre servi ouais ouais c'est
terrible ça c'était mec est couché sur
la bombe demeurent
c'est drôle parce que c'est mais mais ça
raconte ça raconte tellement l'horreur
de tout ce qui s'est passé en bosnie et
tout d'un coup ça vous ou pas ça m'a
fait remonter mes responsabilités là
dessus je trouve qu'on est responsable
de ça mais au premier chef
en tant qu'européens c'est sa mare la
dernière fois que vous avez été d'une
humeur de drogue
y'a pas longtemps quand j'ai fait une
émission pour enfin côté des mecs de
france 2 son d'un film est là pour
atteindre tour eiffel et tous âges était
d'une humeur malmo m deux heures j'avais
pas envie et des fois on est filmé ou
d'interviews puis on a préparé à la télé
et là c'était horrible la dernière fois
que vous avez été le dindon de la farce
mais je suis toujours le dindon de la
farce
quel est votre dada les r1 l'avion le
sauter tout ça ah ouais a sauté dans les
avions marqué c'est la brise
joker dans le dernier les avions
qu'est ce qui peut vous rendre charles
berling muet comme une carpe
[Applaudissements]
l'émotion l'émotion quand que je me
souviens quand mon fils aîné je les
regardais parlera des minutes les bonnes
femmes à côté d'elle mais le sage femme
qui était adorable baptisé balaur
voulait pas lui dire quelque chose c'est
tout ça j'ai regardé les rails voix pour
les césars ou sérénade dire que peu ce
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire rien la
dernière personne qui vous a joué un
tour de cochon le même celui que puisque
c'était celui comment sais tu pas
formule alors votre histoire d'amour
actuelle ouais
est ce qu'elle vous fait toujours un
effet boeuf ou est ce qu'elle va se
terminer en queue de poisson
non elle me fait toujours un effet boeuf
ah ah ouais
est ce que vous êtes à cheval sur les
principes non pas du tout non ce qui
vous énerve le plus c'est les gens qui
sont paresseux comme une couleuvre
orgueilleux comme un paon bête comme une
oie ou bavard comme une pie en bête
comme une oie à bec cominois à 1
dernière question la dernière fois que
vous êtes retrouvés comme un lapin dans
les phares d'une voiture
maintenant ouais je crois que charles
berling
et le film d'anne fontaine comment j'ai
tué mon père
[Applaudissements]
j'accueille maintenant marina picasso
maria vega sobon soir vous publié chez
denoël un livre qui s'appelle grand père
et c'est un type qui n'est pas
complètement innocent puisque pablo
picasso refusé qu'on l'appelle
grand-père donc tout le monde devait
l'appeler pablo et même votre père qui
était son fils unique voilà leur grand
père c'est l'histoire de picasso vu à
travers les yeux de sa petite fille vous
marina picasso ce nom picasso dont vous
dites le porter comme on porte une croix
bien parce que d'avant gens n'avaient
pas la force psychologique
et puis parce que maintenant c'était le
moment de le faire c'est un moment de sa
vie où on peut faire un bilan avec un
certain recul est resté à ses objectifs
alors vous dit j'aurais pu devenir
alcooliques ou drogué il m'a fallu un
long travail thérapeutique
aujourd'hui ses 50 ans mais vous avez
été en analyse de l'âge de 30 ans à
l'âge de 44 ans c'est-à-dire 14 ans
analyse donc pour arriver justement a
récupéré par rapport à l'enfance que
vous avez eu 14 ans à revivre ce qui m'a
détruite pour me reconstruire
alors bon pique à son on va rappeler un
peu voilà ce qu'il y beaucoup de femmes
qu'on va ici quand même le rappeler
avant de vous interviewez 7 6 oui
j'essaie donc picasso donc est à paris
évidemment quand il rencontre votre
grand mère olga khokhlova qu est la
fille d'un colonel russe qu'à dix ans -
clic et un visage de madone et diaghilev
chez qui elle dansait a été dans les
ballets de diaghilev il dit fais gaffe
une russe
on les pousse il épouse et y vivre sera
jamais en fait toute sa vie puisqu'elle
souhaitait marier avec votre grand mère
olga
ah oui c'est ça alors il a un enfant
paulo et dont votre père un messie
divorce pas il trompe très rapidement
votre grand-mère avec marie thérèse
walter blond de regard gris bleu 17 ans
et puis après il ya dora maar ya
françoise gilot cayla maire de paloma
qu'on connaît ensuite il ya jacqueline
roque enfin voilà donc il ya eu beaucoup
de fans dans sa vie alors ce qu'il faut
savoir
c'est picasso je ne savais pas à ce
point là et d'une pingrerie hors du
commun
oui je crois qu'on a eu un parcours
affectif et matériels extrêmement
difficile à oui alors il dit par exemple
il est très sûr de lui c'est qu'il peut
de l'argent très facilement il dit le
vrai prix de mes tableaux s'ils étaient
connus personnes voudraient le payer
donc ses voisins comme un niveau quand
il voit un jour il ya un de ces
marchands qui lui amène un nouveau
billet de 500 francs
il voit laurent blanc au milieu du
billet de 500 francs et dessinent petit
corrida il dit voilà maintenant ça vaut
le double donc il sait très bien quand
il va dans un restaurant il fait un
dessin sur l'addition il paye pas alors
évidemment quand on est enfant ça
surprend comme ça pouvoir créer de la
monnaie d'une certaine façon c'est
difficile de se structurer avec de tels
de telles images
ce qu'on découvre donc c'est qu'il est
très près de ses sous et il est
maléfique grand père mais c'est ça oui
maléfique vous dites d'ailleurs mon
propos n'est pas de dire du mal de
picasso mais de rendre palpable la
souffrance des victimes
victime d'un virus un virus un peu
comparable au fameux virus à ilo veyou
qui a était déchaîné à l'aube de l'an
2000 visites picasso à saccager notre
famille oui oui c'est quand je retrace
un petit peu le le portrait et le
parcours de mon père et de ses
petits-enfants l'occurrence mon frère et
moi même alors votre frère pablito se
suicident deux jours après la mort de
picasso paulo votre père devient un
colis qui meurt d'un cancer du foie à
l'âge de 54 ans voilà et puis en 1977
marie thérèse walter cependant son
garage en 85 jacqueline roque se tire
une balle dans la tête enfin c'est
quelqu'un qui a un qui a produit comme
ça du malheur autour de lui vous avez
été victime d'une certaine façon je suis
je suis déjà sa petite fille donc fait
sa famille mais bon là vous prenez un
petit peu des raccourcis mais je crois
que c'est un petit peu le le prix à
payer quand on a
dans sa famille il faut pas penser que
tout se passe très bien et sur un plan
artistique peut-être mais sur le plan
des relations de familiale c'est
différent il est ce un cimetière
derrière lui c'est ce que j'ai constaté
c'est une réalité mais est-ce que
l'oeuvre mérite autant de sacrifices
humains
je pense que non donc je pense qu avant
même d'être un grand artiste soit humain
faut avoir la sensibilité il faut voir
ce qui se passe autour de soi
ce qui est incroyable dans cette
histoire quand on lit le bouquin qui est
passionnant c'est que picasso qui a fait
gouverne ica qui a quand même fait qui
était communiste qui s'est battu pour la
paix aujourd'hui en france je sais pas
combien de glisse et de collège qui
s'appelle picasso bon et en fait quand
on lit votre bouquin c'est un petit peu
terrible oui mais ça c'est le sait le
regard d'un enfant de sa famille qui qui
relate sa ville qui ne dis pas du mal de
son grand-père qui relate ce qu'elle a
vécu
bien sûr alors dans le livre vous parlez
de votre grand-mère donc de votre père
de votre mère de votre frère alors votre
grand mère souvent maltraités par les
biographes et vous vous essayez de la
réhabiliter d'une certaine façon c'est
dire la vérité parler parce que je suis
sa petite fille je crois que je suis la
seule au jour d'aujourd'hui qui peut le
faire je suis sa seule petite fille pour
lui pour votre grand père olga va
abandonner son pays ses rêves
sa carrière va malgré tout elle mourra
paralysé pas très loin de chez lui et il
ira jamais la voir il a laissé mourir
seul oui c'est vrai alors maintenant on
passe à votre père c'est terrible votre
père paulo donc quand il était petit
c'est un petit dieu quand il était
enfant et bien un jour il a commencé à
l'ignorer je crois que quand on connaît
un petit peu sa peinture il est
représenté dans beaucoup de dessins
tableaux poule en arlequin paulo avec
l'âne et portrait extrêmement tendre et
tout donc course aperçoit qui n'est plus
représenté vous n'avez jamais été
représenté un chat mais ni mon frère car
il a peint des homards des crevettes
l'intrus est massée petit don mais pas
ses petits enfants ses petits-enfants
légitime
oui oui j'avais pas dire ça parce qu'on
a l'impression qu'on fait une différence
mais c'est vrai mais c'est vrai nous
sommes les enfants de son fils sa soeur
brunet et on n'a jamais était pas ouais
alors bombe à votre père donc paulo
c'était un petit peu le factotum le
souffre-douleur de pablo picasso il
achetait ses cadres vous avez des petits
boulots quoi c'est un peu son esclave
non sans un petit peu parlé lui de cette
façon là parce que c'est vrai puis d'une
certaine façon
mon père aimait beaucoup son grand père
et je crois que c'est là sa relation
affective qui l'a fait resté très proche
de son père et c'est la raison pour
laquelle il n'a pas voulu prendre son
indépendance c'est ça il aurait pu se
rebeller
ou tout au moins aller vivre ailleurs
oui nous savez quand on est le fils d'un
grand artiste
on n'a pas beaucoup d'existence donc on
fait ce qu'on peut on se sent tout petit
vous le dire qu'on est aimanté par le
génie oui il était même figé il était
ouais grand picasso lui remettais
l'argent au compte gouttes
il l'obligé à venir mendier l'argent
chez lui une certaine façon c'est à dire
qu'yves il était entretenue par son père
dont il n'avait pas d'indépendance
pécuniaire donc il devait passer par ses
caprices pour vivre convenablement le
détruit donc comme je les dis alcool et
cancer du foie
alors votre maire elle elle portait le
nom de picasso qu'on remporte une
médaille
et alors elle avait épousé un picasso
elle comprenait pas pourquoi n'est pas
une vie meilleure d'une certaine façon
je pense qu'au départ elle était déçu de
voir que ce couple ne marchait pas et
ensuite elle a essayé de donner un sens
à son histoire elle a tous projetés sur
mon grand père est là elle s'est trompée
d'homme je crois alors vos parents donc
autre mère emilia les votre père paul au
divorce
quand vous avez six mois et pablito
votre frère à deux ans et votre mère
finit par faire des ménages
non ma mère a essayé de vivre et de
faire différentes choses et la ville n'a
pas été simple pour elle alors vous un
jour vous êtes malade tuberculose sur
sept enfants par votre mère passe à
peine à l'hôpital votre père lui lui
passent jamais et le médecin écrit à
picasso en disant photogrammes envoyé
cet enfant quelque part à villard de
lans en l'occurrence et donc pic à sion
on voit un peu d'argent ou penser que
c'est par peur du scandale pour pour la
galerie pour éviter un scandale mais je
pense qu'il a fallu lui demandé
plusieurs fois et puis bon il a il a
fini par entendre il a fait quelque
chose ça pas été spontanés nom
lorsqu'elle plus touchants dans votre
dans votre bouquin ce qui est vraiment
fou les larmes aux yeux il faut dire les
choses c'est les visites du jeudi
quand votre père avance comme ça vers la
grille delà de la californie et la
propriété donc habiter picasso vous
habitez aujourd'hui il arrive avec ses
enfants sa femme pour voir son père et
il est renvoyé par le concierge selon
lui ouvre pas la porte on lui dit le
maître travaille le mettre dehors
c'est à l'époque où il vivait avec
jacqueline sa dernière épouse et c'est
vrai qu'elle mettait des barrières
on n'était pas reçue spontanément et
c'était souvent très difficile alors
jacqueline dit le soleil ne veux pas
qu'on le dérange
surnommé mon grand-père le soleil le
dieu bon parce qu'elle le connaît pour
j'allais dire pour quelque chose pour
quelqu'un de surhumain c'était ces
qualificatifs et elle l'admiré temps
qu'elle de traiter de la sorte alors
quand vous êtes admis à rentrer puisque
des jours que l'on pouvait rentrer
l'humiliation est pas moindre
on peut dire d'une certaine façon parce
que lui vous reçoit en slip c'est comme
ça quoi s'est il se présentait de façon
naturelle
hélas non ce qui est terrible c'est
qu'est smeralda la chèvre elle a le
droit de faire ces corps mais je me
donne des petits coups de cornes comme
ça dans les meubles
elle fait des crottes sur les toiles
enfin elle sait que vous vous avez droit
à rien et la chèvre a droit à tout oui
enfin j'ai pris cet exemple parce que
c'est vrai que l'image de la chèvre
avait le droit de vivre en liberté dans
cette propriété et nous on avait
tellement de barrières pour accéder à
notre grand père que quand j'étais petit
je me réfugier vers la chèvre et je lui
dit elle elle a vraiment de la chance un
et je rêvais d'être une chèvre alors il
est très méchant très méchant avec son
fils dans votre père ai dit tu es
médiocre tu me fait perdre mon temps
enfin l'humilie comme ça me manquait
vraiment d'humanité il manquait vraiment
de compassion pour la race humaine
surtout pour son fils oui oui oui oui
parce qu'après il est copain avec les
acteurs américains avec il est allé
bouffer jusqu'à 3 heures du matin encore
il avait beaucoup d'amis ça c'était
autre chose c'est pas sa famille c'était
un autre impôt ouais alors picasso meurt
à l'âge de 92 ans deux jours plus tard
votre grand frère pardon pablito il va
devant les grilles de la maison et les
renvoyer et on accepte pas qu'ils
rentrent dans cette maison alors que son
grand père venait de mourir il absorbe
de l'eau de javel et ce qui est terrible
c'est que faute d'argent il peut pas
l'emmener dans un hôpital à marseille et
il agonise pendant 90 jours pendant
trois mois à l'hôpital de la fontonne
entier oui c'est vrai et on n'a pas pu
le sauver je pense qu'on n'aurait pas pu
le sauver davantage mais on n'a même pas
pu tenter cette chance alors il vous dit
un truc d'une grande beauté il vous dit
c'est un peu pour vous qui s'est tuée
d'une certaine façon et vous dites
désormais ils s'occuperont de toi
désormais ils sauront que tu existes
donc d'une certaine façon issue si molle
un peu dans ses quatre ans d'existence
oui je pense qu'il pensait qu'à travers
ce geste ils allaient faire réagir ma
famille il était bien loin du compte
ils ont personne n'a bougé ouais et
quand votre père vient le voir à la
fontonne ils refusent de le voir parce
qu'il était malade déjà depuis deux mois
et je pense qu'il sentait qu'il allait
bientôt mourir et il n'avait n'avait
plus envie de cette visite pensé que
c'était trop tard donc il meurt à 24 ans
après trois mois d'agonie et votre mère
vous dit à ce moment là c'est toi qui
aurait dû mourir pas lui je comprends
vous ayez fait 14 en analyse même à la
limite je trouve que c'est déjà bien
d'un fr vous en êtes aujourd'hui
alors ensuite la bataille sur l'héritage
beaucoup d'argent 6 milliards de francs
s'achète pas c'est rien c'est pas
important
demandez à loïc c'est rien du tout 6
milliards de francs bataille juridique
enfin ce qui est en ce qui me concerne
n'ai pas eu tellement de batailles
juridiques puisque jeune héritière
directe et les autres plus tôt mais ça
n'a pas duré trop longtemps donc je
crois que ça a duré 7 8 ans pour une
succession comme celle là c'est quoi
c'est pas énorme non vous avez droit à
un cinquième et les autres petits
enfants les illégitimes et endroit un
dixième oui ça de ce calcul est à peu
près comme ça oui hélas ce que vous êtes
riche oui oui par héritage - vous avez
25 ans vous retrouver avec beaucoup
d'argent
oui je me trouve dans une situation
assez contrasté mais c'est vrai qu'à
cette époque gens n'avaient pas
tellement envie
puisque je n'en avais pas eu pendant
tant d'années c'était un peu dénué de
sens dans la mesure où mon frère et mon
père était mort je voyais vraiment une
utilité à ce moment là de 7 à vous
acheter quand même une maison à votre
mère oui oui vous avez de l'argent à des
gens qui ont été sympa avec vous pendant
toutes ces années c'est gentil c'est des
changes
vous avez bon coeur vous je crois qu'il
faut avoir du coeur non je suis humaine
vous avez vous êtes sûrement vous êtes
au début vous acheter une moto une
porsche ou une ferrari vous rendez
compte que c'est des conneries quand
même commencé sa forme est aussi sympa
j'aime j'aime beaucoup courir mais bon
ouf j'avais j'avais des choses à vivre
j'essayais de l'aider puis je me suis
rendu compte que ce n'était pas tous
rapidement dont vous faites une
fondation pour les orphelins au vietnam
dont vous occupez vous adopté trois
enfants vietnamiens aussi oui c'est un
côté positif de la vie je pense que
c'est bien d'avoir rendu à des enfants
ce que moi je n'ai pas eu lorsque
j'étais enfant et puis me donne beaucoup
donc c'est un bon échange vous avez
pensé que vous avez acheté votre compère
d'une certaine façon non sur un plan
humain je pense que j'ai beaucoup
compensé de choses qui n'a pas fait pour
sa famille et sur un concepteur enfants
et vous faites pour des gens qui sont
pas obligatoires enfin vous avez vu des
enfants biologiques je dirais mais vous
avez aussi des enfants adoptés oui alors
bon quand il ya l'histoire de citroën
qui rachète le nom de picasso vous ça
vous effondre interne on commet des gens
tellement d'argent peuvent-ils aller
revendre leur nom est ce un peu stupide
de vendre son nom pour de l'argent moi
je n'ai appris par la presse comme tout
le monde j'ai j'ai fait un procès à mai
à ma famille j'étais dégoûté parce que
j'étais la seule à vouloir annuler ce
contrat donc voilà maintenant
aujourd'hui devant un fait accompli bon
mais je ne peux plus rien faire mais moi
j'ai essayé de faire quelque chose
jonças priest votre vie de femme n'a pas
été facile au milieu de tout ça non non
non je crois que c'est pas facile
d'avoir un nom aussi lourd d'être
héritière est bon et d'être comprise à
plein d'endroits d'en face et la vie la
fortune isole oui oui oui c'est isole
tensions dans le gouvernement il ya un
blanc ou dit ça je veux pas raconter
c'est une part solitaire de vos deux
enfants c'est le père mes deux enfants
et je crois que c'est une histoire qui
ne concerne que mes deux grands enfants
et moi même et ça n'a pas d'intérêt pour
les autres donc j'ai laissé un blanc
aux rations ademe
louis valentin sachet de noël
vous n'échapperez pas une courte
interview mais très facile rassurez vous
comme vous est la petite-fille de
picasso c'est une interview couleurs
c'est normal on ne bouge pas pendant le
jingle
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui vous rend vert de rage
quand une personne que j'aime me fait
attendre vous avez attendu ça qu'est-ce
qui vous répondrai pas qu'est ce qui
vous rend rouge de honte quand on y lit
une personne dans ma présence qu'est ce
qu'ils vont en bleu de peur quand je me
trouve nez à nez avec une souris ah bon
eros de bonheur quand ma fille née
remportent des conflits des compétitions
hippiques
qu'est ce qui vous fait rire jaune quand
mes enfants asiatiques jouent au
football dans mes salles ont eu à des
primes très près
ces deux
je vais vous laisser filer marina merci
d'être venus en tous les cas et tabac
réserver votre première télévision pour
nous courage
larry brown
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et maintenant
précis bréger nielsen là
il fallait que je fasse bien sûr comment
ça va sinon ça va très bien alors nous
avons notre traductrice habituel chez
scholes belinda
don
bonsoir bonsoir s'est fait sur la route
chez votre meilleur j'aimerais vous y
voir l'accueil d'être largué je suis
ravi d'être ici
cette édition il s'est vraiment écrire
de vous rencontrer
ouais avec free selon moi la différence
à l'entrée à l'américaine
maintenant vous travaillez sous le nom
de gi taki votre vrai nom en fait dit à
nielsen aurez vous êtes né au danemark
très belle et à l'âge de 17 ans vous
devenez mannequins comme vous étiez
petit étiez très grande un peu trop
grande
et quand il y avait le jeu de qui
embrasse qui quand il y avait le jeu de
quilles embrasse qui aucun garçon ne
voulez vous embrasser c'est sûrement
vrai nom vais essayer ce soir je vais
commencer avec vous
[Applaudissements]
mais si je suis un coup moi ça marche
pour moi très bien mon petit très bien
on continue tous les deux ou quatre
mille ou 4000 ou quérir donc au début
j'ai su sérieuses il a fait pour acter
ce cas vous savez il n'est pas marié en
plus faut y aller
j'aime bien celui qui est en face des
rues
ce soir personne mais marié bien leurs
débuts vous avez la vocation de la
musique parce que dès l'âge de 5 ans
vous chanter dans la chorale de l'église
vous êtes doué pour la flûte quand vous
n'êtes pas fait ça dépend ce qu'on veut
dire vous êtes posé vous épousez gaspard
donc
vous avez un fils avec lui et vous le
laisser se casse par votre premier mari
voulu laisser l'enfant de faire au
passage pour aller faire un film avec
avec arnold schwarzenegger
quoi alors mon dieu non je vais vous
tuer un jour eh bien pourquoi
à moins de masse à venir côté
oui
est assez minime
ça
doyen des noms j'explique premier film
donc avec arnold schwarzenneger dino de
laurentiis vous voit en couverture de
photo magazine et il vous trouve sublime
et il vit voilà vous êtes mannequin il
faut devenir
est-ce que je ne suis pas super bien
j'ai dit bon voilà je comprends dire de
la rente hissant même temps et alors là
vous partez aux usa et
dans un hôtel à new york il avoue fait
passer alors après shirt sénégal fait
passer un petit mot un sylvester
stallone en mettant mon nom mon nom et
birgit j'aimerais vraiment vous
rencontrez il va carrément voici mon
numéro de téléphone c'est vrai que j'ai
le disons mais si mon numéro de
téléphone est en fait qu il faut dire
faut dire la vérité veut dire la vérité
quand vous étiez petit
vous aviez vu rocky numéro un merci et
quand vous avez vu rocky quand j'étais
petit voyez rocky numéro avec votre papa
et vous tomber amoureuse très jeunes de
saint viateur stallone jeudi c'est
simplement que j'ai envoyé deux lettres
j'ai dit je suis dit ah je viens de
finir mon premier film voilà qui je suis
je ne veux pas votre autographes mais je
voudrais vous dire si vous êtes
intéressé passez moi un petit coup de
fil à dire oh ça va
et voilà alors il vous appelle il vous
appelle vous vous retrouvez au bar de
l'hôtel vous dîné ensemble oui à la
maïzena en fait on a eu une belle
rencontre
je vais remettre mais je n'ai le temps
c'est comme ça
c'est très los angeles et alors ensuite
évidemment vous allez à los angeles où
vous tournez vous jouez dans rocky iv
vous tournez dans cobra et à ce moment
là
sylvester stallone divorce de sa femme
il la laisse sa femme avec ses enfants
pour vivre avec vous les enfants qui
mélina que oui tu me la fais cette
phrase oui mais j'ai fait je les fais
bien donc stallone stallone à ce
moment-là quitte la mère de ses enfants
sacha pour ce pour vivre avec vous ils
tombent très amoureux de vous sylvester
stallone idea non vous savez ce qu'il a
dit il a dit en parlant de vous un il a
dit elle a du coeur
elle a de l'humour elle est capable de
prouesses athlétiques
elle a un instinct maternel formidable
alors vous venez d'en abandonner votre
fils julian avec son père caspar mais
bon il dit elle a un instinct maternel
formidable
il y à même le sol et je suis vraiment
un six à dix après le combat contre
apple aux cris de ils en sortent
la famille il avait fait de l'effet des
rayons on atterrit non je suis pas du
tout intéressé parce que vous dites je
parle pas le français je comprends pas
de lancer je peux vous dire une chose je
suis pas venu ici pour entendre cette
mère d'un don voilà donc il dit que vous
aimez la famille d'une façon
traditionnelle
évidemment il va déchanter puisque deux
ans après deux ans après vous divorcez
et la mère de stallone sais pas si c'est
vrai vous à nous dire si c'est vrai la
mère de sylvester stallone dit vous
avoir trouvé au lit avec votre
secrétaire particulière kelly c'est vrai
ou c'est pas vrai dès que je puisse vous
dire à tous soyez français italiens
danois ou quel que soit votre origine et
suffit de regarder un petit peu mon cas
c'est parce que j'aime les armes 1 et
elle le sexe mais j'adore les femmes
j'adore la beauté des femmes même et
j'en suis sûr une femme qui adore les
hommes c'est tout mais je suis également
une personne généreuse et je m'occupe
des gens comme juste maintenant quand
même ma mère je m'en occupe
et on arrête un
sylvester stallone a déclaré à la suite
de son mariage avec biarritz singh a
déclaré j'ai commis trois erreurs dans
la vie vous c'est une c'est fatima lui
l'a dit j'ai commis trois erreurs dans
ma vie bien vite nielsen birgit nilsson
birgit nilsson et le divorce lui a coûté
70 millions 70 millions de gays qui te
guette un rite et le divorce a coûté 70
millions de dollars voilà alors quoi
quoi quoi quoi quoi quoi quoi quoi quoi
quoi quoi quoi quoi quoi quoi quoi
ok connaître alors après vous devenez
animatrice chez berlusconi quand amanda
vie et adriana voilà elle a un souffle à
dos léger l'oreillette j'enlève
l'oreillette j'aurais plus rien parce
que j'ai déjà je me sentis associés
et surtout sur trois à watts et un prix
que c'est gagné c'est un auteur
ok allez
ah oui je me sens si bien
tout est tellement petit monde a bien
suivi
oui il ya eu 15 par il ya eu sylvester
stallone
vous travaillez
m
bon alors en 81 enfin bon on va papa
1 dites lui de linda et leur livret
[ __ ] j'en ai même pas jouer avec ce
truc
elle a une réputation de croqueuse
d'hommes dit lui fut alors aujourd'hui
vous êtes marié oui non non vous entend
maintenant vous êtes marié jette marier
avec un homme qui est un pilote
automobile qui s'appellera ou le
meilleur ortolani j'habitais au lac de
lugano et vous êtes une fille rangée
oui je peux dire c'est que vous avez
rencontrés à sanaa dimanche vous êtes
vous avez gagné
voilà alors en 4 alors dont il ya quand
même un problème en 1900 je sais pas si
c'est vrai vous allez nous dire un mais
en 1997
vous auriez passé une nuit dans un
palace au cap d'antibes pour un million
de dollars avec un prince saoudien
vrai ou pas belinda traduit baho
c'est sûrement que cela tombait encore
c'est brachetti bravo vous êtes content
n'a maintenant vous êtes une bande mois
sédentaires cgt fapt non non vous
n'étiez pas dans le palace non puisqu'il
paraît que le mec il n'arrivait pas à se
payer pamela anderson
ils ont pris bien rythmé pour un million
de dollars tu serais toi mais la belle
histoire le petit tour je parle toujours
non plus que quelqu'un ce soir ici avec
nous pour terminer la soirée
c'est un académicien voici les corps
sénat
ok rigueur sénat de l'académie française
belinda ce jeu pouvait traduire quand
même content du tout pour vous thierry
voilà de l'académie française
si on m'avait dit que les mimos
maintenant si on m'avait dit que
l'académie bach est m'aiderait à mada
l'académie mana tout vous savez bien
c'est ce qui change à l'académie
[Musique]
jean baptiste mondino et chanter à
l'académie alors avec orsenna de
l'académie française
prix goncourt maître de requêtes au
conseil d'état
alors votre vrai nom eric arnould
orsenna c'est un nom de plume c'est le
nom de la citadelle mythique du roman de
julien gracq qui a écrit donc le rivage
des syrtes
et quel prix goncourt en 51 qu'il a
refusé vous l'avez accepté quand même
jamais refusé le goncourt c'est refuser
un chèque de 50 francs ouais mais c'est
pas refuser les droits d'auteurs des
ventes a donc à d'accueil et le refus du
goncourt
alors levine approche artisanale de la
littérature de l'écriture ou dit c'est
un peu comme la marqueterie vous êtes un
peu comme ça le papier la gomme le
crayon peuvent et on met les petits les
petites phrases les monnaies petit on
bouge un peu les choses c'est pas
tellement intellectuelle il s'agit de il
s'agit de de s'approcher un peu de la
vérité du personnage ou la vérité je
suis un pragmatique de la littérature
oui oui c'est un métier comme un autre
qui raconte l'histoire comme comme vous
on raconte essaye d'aller le plus vrai
possible delà de la vérité d'un
personnage et vous citez souvent cette
phrase de nourissier un romancier c'est
celui qui passe deux jours pour vérifier
le nom d'un arbre oui parce que ce qui
est formidable c'est une part de lui
même à la guitare veut parler que sa
guitare question pour le professeur ça
veut dire aujourd'hui d'être pragmatique
ça veut dire que c'est à dire que cette
batterie oui mais qu'est ce que vous
avez dit oui non c'est à dire que ne
sait pas forcément intellectuelle ça
passe pas par des théories on essaye de
pratiquer et on s'aperçoit est ce que
cette scène marche cette scène marche
pas est-ce que ce dialogue et mais
est-ce que ce dialogue n'est même pas
j'ai pas besoin de faire encore une fois
de reprendre des tas de l'état de 10 des
jeux constaté puis à l'oreille et puis à
la vérité c'est comme une autre juste
une autre fautrat là et j'ai fait pas
mal aussi de scénario et de dialogue de
six marins de chine
il y avait il y avait des phrases qui
marchait pas c'était faux c'était faux
et alors j'aime bien essayer d'être
juste même si c'est tout simple tweet
c'est bien d'entendre quelqu'un d'aussi
intelligent que vous qui parle comme un
enfant quand vous vous êtes présenté en
particulier c'est très très bien vieilli
en forte à émouvoir et j'ai trouvé le
mans ça authentique
non c'est vrai
regardez sa vieille en janvier enfin sa
vieille enfants dont 10 à une ode vous
savez que charles berling sa famille
vient du danemark il d'aniche
non on était loin tous les deux familles
l'isda il soudainement arrêté d'avoir
ils s'écrivaient qui est excellent
ouais bah oui blixen blixen gens là le
stade babemba touchent par leur côté
comme ça utiliser
mais non
messieurs
au sida
l'académie binda et oui expliqué à notre
ami qui fait partie de l'académie
française quand même mis ce qui fait un
mais je crois que ça ne respire pas plus
de respect que ça va quand même
attendait l'académie française
d'immortel il est devenu mortel oui ma
mère est une chanson douce
erik orsenna penser sans doute jaloux
c'est un livre qui se vend très bien non
vraiment oui c'est un j'ai pas besoin de
promotion venu ici pour rencontrer l'ex
femme de sylvester mais en fait vous en
foutez ça se vend très bien
c'est un gros succès alors racontez nous
parce que là je crois que dans l'état où
tout le monde et ça va être très
compliqué donc ce qu'on va faire si vous
pouvez vous vous occupez de rien je peux
de gitta le temps que orsenna raconte
son livre donc qui s'appelle donc la
grammaire est une chanson douce chez
stock gros succès une fable illustré
d'aquarelles un petit peu un hommage au
cou petit prince un hommage au petit
prince ça j'ai du mal à trouver ce qu'on
va faire essayer de nous raconter le
bouquin bon il s'agit dakota qui
explique que deux enfants sont perdus
comme ça dans une île et non non non
c'est intéressant vous est très
intéressant et perdu dans une île qui
réapprennent à parler alors on leur ré
apprendre des mots on leur dit que les
mots sont des êtres vivants qui peuvent
aider à mieux vivre parce que quand on a
peu de mots on a une petite vie et quand
on veut être très amoureux ont une fois
aller dans des endroits un peu trouble
un peu secret de la vie et pour ça il
faut des expressions un peu nouvelle est
que à répéter sans arrêt les mêmes mots
on a des amours qui sont sans arrêt les
mêmes et à la fin on s'ennuie donc la
grammaire c'est ce qui permet de lier
les mots comme le solfège permet de
relier entre elles les natures j'ai fini
ça a été bref et un milieu mais vrai
non c'est magnifique
d'ailleurs c'est pas moi qui leur ai dit
ça a énormément derrière magnifique vous
avez été longtemps avec orsenna
collaborateur de françois mitterrand
vous n'avez jamais été président la
république
pas encore mais on va faire une
interview si j'étais président on est
prêt pour l'événement
landing en ébauche parlant le génial si
vous étiez présent quelle serait la
première loi que vous décrèterait au
lieu d'avoir abandonné complètement le
service militaire en le remplaçant par
rien j'aurais demandé à tous les
français petit entre 17 et 20 ans
d'aller passer trois mois en afrique
d'accord ça changera leur vision du
monde quel serait votre devise dont la
france existait et accueillir comment
appelleriez vous le prochain porte
avions nucléaire français bateau à voile
alors le dalaï lama est de passage à
paris eric oui je préside la république
si vous le recevez la chine annuler une
commande de 80 airbus
surtout en ce moment parce que ça et
c'est un peu dur les russes comme je
suis en cohabitation je charge le
premier ministre
on l'accusé le présent aussi à ça c'est
beaucoup c'est ça aussi ça lui fait
réaliser vous êtes rencontrés à l'elysée
là tous les deux alors ce qu'il dit est
vrai il dit beaucoup havas d'après ce
que j'ai pu lire et je savais pas tout
enfin il y eu pas mal de vérité oui
alors on vous convie aux obsèques de
fidel castro qui vient de mourir
j'y vais pas vous seriez un bon
président jamais assez bien non jamais
mais j'étais de voter pour vous alesi
qui prouve riez vous comme conseiller
spirituel
si vous étiez président mais peut-être
vouloir de plus en plus maintenant un
athée un athée comme réussie et
spirituelle oui ça m un peu d'air qui
refusent auriez-vous à l'académie
ce qui m'ennuie parce que c'est quand
même une affaire qui dure jusqu'au bout
ouais donc on peut pas les virer oui
jacques séguéla par exemple vous
accepteriez qu'il entre à l'académie
écoutez j'en parlerai son [ __ ]
c'est là la grammaire est une chanson
douce
doussot la vie
messieurs
et maintenant on passe au blind test un
blind test dédié ce soir à valérie
launay voilà c'est pas qui c'est mais
pour moi elle est très importante c'est
un blind test
mon nom est une couleur donc le nom des
gens qui chantent est un nom de couleur
en français ou en anglais
et pour arbitrer le blind test j'appelle
mangera fait les portiers
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
puis quand tu as messieurs ouais c'est
un jeu mal la main mais ça c'est dire
que je suis je suis attendu ce soir à
dire mais moi d'appelants rob blake des
attentions
les chanteurs ont des noms de couleurs
didier attention attention lavoine près
première chanson didier intentions
sur ce point
hello
messieurs ils sont vraiment
alors
[Musique]
médias attention talent ya des liens si
un soufflage il ya des habits ya déjà
fait maintenant talia je rigole pas ce
soir si à soufflage et déshabille hockey
attention souffle à bien didier
[Musique]
chambly
à
non jamais
ouattara
gore désir très bien attention didier
en continu avant 6 ans
au stadium nord 15h45 flash quoi il va
là bas
nous avons su
verdict je suis sûr qu'ils sont au
dessus de tout soupçon bien attention à
dosso kossara goulasch
[Musique]
je
moi ici voilà
[Applaudissements]
c'est fait
à lundi quand l'animal t-shirt regarde
en coin évidemment oui
une annonce une fille l'un des petits
salons on est bien les regarder non
chaque fois que j'ai laissé mais
attention attention vous avez - vous
marrer la donation didier
ouais
[Applaudissements]
génial énorme dose non seulement une
grande partie de nous didier attention
attention attention son nom et au nom de
couleur didier jonas
ribéry des ja replay y arriver y arriver
est serge
[Musique]
marc lavoine
james ridgeway
[Applaudissements]
attention c'est beau double dur didier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de toute façon de toute façon maintenant
c'est le super banco vous gsm est là
bien faire juste comme ça qu'elle a
c'est injuste mais habite je sais dire
que là maintenant celui qui trouve le
super banco à gagner même si c'est le
cours gagnait jusqu'à présent celui qui
trouve le super banco à gagner attention
vous avez des jt des trucs arriviez
c'est dur c'est dur c'est pas son nom et
au nom de couleur neutre couleur son
manteau de couleur
[Applaudissements]
une
m
dix couleurs
oui oui ouais ouais
[Applaudissements]
alors
ouais voilà mesdames messieurs c'était
comme on en parle l'émission la vie
quotidienne
six clubs en tournée le 9ème
les tours le 10 à rennes et 29 ans 31
décembre à l'olympia vhs et dvd du
spectacle le 22 novembre
j'aime anthisnes célarié madame
sans-gêne mise en scène d'alain sexe à
partir du 18 octobre au théâtre antoine
et le single
le canada avec charme chimiste et
pompons en vente le 18 octobre si le
livre jaune obligeant à faire l affaire
d'état aux éditions du cherche-midi
merci merci 2000 et jj miller
jenny bel'air une peinture de françois
ajouté chez pauvert merci j'ai l'immense
nouveau marc lavoine album le 9 octobre
et le signaler
après j'ai tout oublié merci rendre
hommage la voir charles berling comment
j'ai tué mon père d'anne fontaine avec
michel bouquet natacha régnier
michel bouquet charles berling livre
d'entretiens publié chez grasset marie
n'a plus qu'un seul grand père j'ai de
noël bien
au sénat la grammaire est une chanson
douce chez stock
nitot qui finit quand ils vivent à
l'intérieur des vi nations
[Applaudissements]
rendez vous lundi soir pour 520
pas de vainqueur
m
[Musique]
nord
m
[Musique]
il devait même
il
[Musique]
mais voilà
test nous tue
[Musique]
et
quand
utile
[Musique]
à
la mer
[Musique]
m
oh
[Musique]
non